at eight thirty nine a.m. and I'd like to commence by saluting the flag member Lewis
Will you please lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance.
Having now resumed our very first in-person session in the last two plus years I am going to adjourn into closed session.
Nice to see you all. I ask that the members of the public please leave the board room and board members please turn off their microphones.
And during closed session the board will discuss and or take action on the following case E.E. versus state and we'll see you back here in just a few moments.
We're back. So we have just in closed session discussed and taken action on the following legal matter the E.E. versus state case and we are launching our May meeting now.
The May revision as you know to the governor's budget was made available last week. I'll include some more details under my president's report.
I want to thank everyone who is here for wearing their masks and being safe. We are in the middle of a little surge and so we really appreciate everyone's consideration there.
There is a handout on the table in the lobby identifying the proposed items on the consent calendars the proposed waiver consent items are W 1 through 10.
The proposed regular consent items are items 5 through 11. We will take up the waiver consent items just after our lunch break and the regular consent items later this afternoon after item 4.
We will reopen item 1 SBE priorities later this afternoon to take action on the March 2022 minutes and take up the state board liaison reports.
Members of the public who wish to phone in for public comment should view the live stream of the meeting to know at what time public comment will occur for each item.
Public comment may be provided by dialing the phone number entering a participant access code and then following each of the operators prompts upon dialing in callers will be added to a caller queue.
The operator will notify callers when it is their turn to provide public comment will also ask callers to please turn down the speaker volume of their computers if they are following the live webcast to avoid an echoing effect.
Members of the public wishing to provide public comment in person should sign in using the binder at the table just outside the room.
The binder is on the table with separate pages for each item number. This will help ensure that staff is able to track the in person speakers for a particular item.
Public comment by phone or in person will be limited to one minute for each speaker. Item 12 is the general public comment item during which members of the public may provide comment on any member matters that are not specifically listed on this meeting's board agenda.
And item one is our state board projects and priorities item.
I will give my report and then following that state superintendent Thurman will be here to give his.
So here we are.
May
May is a happy time in education, not just because summer break is around the corner, but it's also when we celebrate the accomplishments of the year and there's much to celebrate.
May kicked off California Teacher Appreciation Week and I would like to express my sincere gratitude for all the educators out there.
Of course, a week is not enough time to fully appreciate teachers who should be recognized every week of the year for the important work that they do every day.
Teachers are the profession on which all other professions depend and so we want to acknowledge and encourage our teachers to recharge and renew.
In the weeks to follow this week is classified school employees appreciation week another joyful moment and should be celebrated year round and I want to give.
A special shout out to all the people in our schools who make it possible for students to learn and grow in so many ways, thank you for all that you do.
Over the next several weeks we'll see our wonderful senior students don robes and caps for graduation ceremonies so congratulations to the class of 2022.
In future years when people discuss the character traits necessary for a good happy life traits like perseverance determination persistence resilience, they will point to this class.
As a primary example of young people pushing through adversity to reach a goal, all of our grads are special and I want to wish good fortune to our student board member.
Rana is taking her international baccalaureate exam this morning, and she will be with us to celebrate this afternoon and i'm sure she's going to feel like celebrating after that is over.
Six California seniors were recognized by US Secretary of Education Miguel Cardona last week among the 58th class of the US presidential scholars.
These young people are recognized by the White House Commission on presidential scholars for their accomplishments and academics.
The arts career technical fields and their demonstrated commitment to community service and leadership, the California scholars include reverse reverse Java who attends mission San Jose high school in Fremont.
me a su Gino lock nada high school in locking out of Flintridge Catherine's bivouacos key at Menlo Atherton high school.
In Atherton entered she at Palos Verdes Peninsula high school in rolling hills estates Vivian he at Palos Verdes Peninsula high school.
In rolling hills estates and Madeline Elaine case, who is that viewpoint school in Calabasas congratulations we're very proud to have these great teens representing our state.
And last month on earth day.
Secretary cardona also recognized for California schools and a school district as recipients of the US Department of Education green ribbon school honors.
And these schools are recognized for their work on sustainability healthy and safe school environments and hands on learning experiences that connect students to the world around them.
To the world around them and we're making a lot of progress, as you know, in the state on green schools and we expect to make a lot more progress.
We want to congratulate could tell a high school in Anaheim Swiss and Valley K eight school in Fairfield St Martin of tours Academy and La Mesa and Altamont Creek elementary school in livermore.
Plus the merced union high school district in at water, which was honored as a district sustainability awardee.
Continuing the good news governor news from relief to release his may budget revision on Friday.
As a result of expanding state revenues California's projected budget surplus is nearly $100 billion more than the entire budget of every other state in the country, except New York and Texas.
So new governor Newsom's provide revised proposal does make a significant additional investments in education provides unprecedented levels of investment in our schools, we at one time, we're one of the lowest spending states in the nation, and we are now well above the national average and continuing to move in the right direction.
The governor's budget plan includes the highest level per pupil funding in our state's history strategies to stabilize and support schools in terms of attendance as they recover from the challenges of coven 19 funds to accelerate local efforts necessary to support those most affected by the pandemic.
Adding more student learning time to the school day funding improvements for school and children nutrition expanding pre kindergarten programs.
And moving forward, of course, on plans for universal TK the may revise includes ongoing and expanded investments to address the teacher shortage and the school counselor shortage, as well as initiatives to expand the pipeline for TK teachers.
Our additional funds for further expanding the number of resource rich community schools, which we will hear about later today.
We're all very excited for that item. We will be voting to approve the initial grantees for the planning grants, the implementation grants of whom there are more than we had anticipated and the new technical assistance center the enthusiasm from the field is palpable, and I really want to say the hard work of the state department of education staff to accomplish this has been extraordinary, some of them are with us right now, and we'll hear from them shortly.
These are the right investments at the right time and they're crucial to implementation of the California for all kids plan, which is designed to empower families and parents with more options and more services.
And to address inequities in educational opportunities and outcomes.
We look forward to the legislature passing a final budget in June that prioritizes students and families in other important news on Monday, the 60 day field review period for the revised draft of the mathematics framework closed.
I would like to thank everyone who took the time to send in comments and suggestions and thoughts CDE fielded more than 300 comments, many of them quite meaty and offering dozens and dozens of suggestions for line edits and other changes.
With a 900 page document, it's not unusual to get hundreds of pages of requested edits and we will take them very seriously.
The work now with CDA staff is to review, organize and evaluate the comments to develop a plan for revision.
Once we have an understanding of the scope of the proposed changes, we will need to make a determination about when the framework is likely to come before the end of the year, and we will take that very seriously.
I would like to thank everyone who took the time to send in comments and suggestions and thoughts CDE fielded more than 300 comments, many of them quite meaty and offering dozens and dozens of suggestions for line edits and other changes.
I look forward to digging into the comments and understanding the insights from those who have taken the time to participate.
That's exactly what the process is for, giving the public a voice and an opportunity to be heard.
This is an important opportunity for the state and it's important that we get this framework right.
The United States has declined for many years in its mathematics performance on PISA, which is the international assessment ranking well below the international average.
And California has improved its standing in the last few years, but we still rank below the national average in the United States.
The United States has been plagued by math teacher shortages for about a half a century, and many states and districts have struggled to find a curriculum approach that makes math come alive and become meaningful for most students,
while encouraging and enabling a substantial number of students to be well prepared to enter STEM fields.
This is especially critical in our state where we need to grow a diverse and highly capable STEM workforce, a workforce that is vital to the future of the state.
So this framework process, while it will continue to take considerable time and effort, comes at an important moment when the first common core line framework,
there was an immediate need to push out guidance to the field because the standards were so new and different teachers needed help in adjusting instruction.
And while the speed of the effort was appreciated, we also heard from the field that the 2013 framework wasn't as helpful as some had hoped.
And now we have the benefit of teachers who have been working with these standards for more than a decade.
Many know and understand the standards well, and it gives us an opportunity to really dig into the best practices of the past 12 years and the years of data around common core aligned instruction.
We will take the time needed to do the work well to ensure quality and opportunity, excellence and equity in mathematics instruction to give every student the opportunity to love mathematics and to excel in it.
Finally, on a cautionary note, I do want to urge all of us to remain vigilant in our efforts to contain the spread of covid, which is still with us.
Unfortunately, that covid case rates are up, rising with the B.A. to variant reported covid 19 cases among children number 93,511 in the U.S.
last week, up more than 50 percent from the previous week in California.
Our overall case rates have increased by nearly 400 percent since the beginning of April, from about 100 on average per day to nearly 400 per day.
Hospitalizations are going up here and nationally, and death rates are following and beginning to rise once again.
I have personally lost two family members to covid, and I know across our state, many families have been affected disproportionately in the African-American, Pacific Islander and Latin X communities.
But all communities have felt this pain.
Fear's board of these experiences have kept many students, including a disproportionate number of students with disabilities, out of school.
And I know that families and educators are struggling to enact and sustain mitigation strategies at home and at school.
This is a time when we need to double down on safety, especially as large events are occurring at the end of the school year, proms and graduation ceremonies and the like.
There was an article in the newspaper recently about proms as a super spreader, a super spreader events in a couple of districts.
I attended my son's graduation from UC Berkeley School of Public Policy on Monday, and I was thrilled that the hundreds of people in attendance, every single person was masked and cheering.
And I thank everyone who is here for showing their concern for their own safety and that of others by wearing a mask.
We'll need to watch the indicators and continue to focus on the mitigation strategies we know work, including continuing to encourage vaccinations across California.
Only 36 percent of children ages five through 11 have completed the vaccine.
And of all of us need to be aware of boosters so we can continue California's track record of saving lives relative to other large states and keeping children and adults safe.
And there are so many boosters. I'm up to number four.
I don't know how many keeping track.
I'm happy that our colleagues in public health are working to address these issues by centering on equity, by prioritizing high need schools and state funded vaccine and testing programs.
And on that note of cautious optimism, I'd like to pass the mic to State Superintendent Tony Thurman.
Tony, it's great to see you.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond.
Good morning to you and to the members of the board and to all who are here today in person for this meeting.
It's great to be with you in person and to bring you greetings on behalf of all of the staff at the California Department of Education and on behalf of our students and our schools.
As you provided your report, President Darling-Hammond, I thought about what this school year has been like.
And I'm grateful to the 50 to 60 schools that have invited me and given me the opportunity to visit them as this school year began and it has school reopened.
And I have to acknowledge Dr. Escobedo.
I believe your district at the time when you were still leading Chula Vista was the very first school district that I visited in July, one of our earlier opening districts.
And I can say that what I saw there and I've seen throughout that in spite of all the challenges that our nation in our world is experiencing, students continue to learn and they continue to thrive.
There's no doubt that we have in this experience in these last two years experienced what I think are the toughest moments that we'll experience in our lifetime.
And there's no doubt that there have been a spotlight has been put on the inequities that have existed in the educational system for a very long time.
But we are resilient people and our students have demonstrated incredible resilience.
Our educators have demonstrated ingenuity and creativity in the face of very difficult circumstances.
Our families have been persistent and have juggled to be co-partners in education and caring for their kids and balancing work needs.
And the state of California has put forward, I think, perhaps the greatest plan that we've ever seen as it relates to providing the kinds of resources that will allow California schools that I believe to first heal from the trauma of the pandemic,
to make academic recovery and then to thrive as we prepare our students for tomorrow.
We certainly have a lot of work to do, but California is well poised to build something better than what we had before.
I do want to acknowledge the tragic events of the last week.
You know, the continuing acts of hate that we've seen play out against the black community and places like Buffalo,
the tragic events that we've seen here in California, you know, shootings in churches, you know, that we continue to see acts of hate that take place.
And they're not all in California.
Many are many of these acts of hate that we see happen in places outside of our state, but they do have an impact on our students in California.
I'm grateful that on yesterday I had the opportunity to spend time with a great organization called Gender Nation that has provided gender affirming books for LGBTQ plus students.
And it was a wonderful celebration.
And I'm mindful that California students are experiencing higher rates of depression because of the kinds of statements being made in other states against our LGBTQ plus students and our trans students,
that black students are experiencing depression in higher rates, that all students have experienced depression in higher rates.
I can think of nothing more important than making sure we address the social emotional needs of our students.
And so I'm grateful for today's presentation on community schools and what that three billion dollar investment means in the new proposed investment for community schools.
We've had a great partnership with the state board staff and our board liaisons, Dr. Darlingham and Dr. Escobedo, working hand in hand on how to really steer this incredible initiative.
And I'll say that I'll save the details for the presentation that will be coming up shortly.
But this has to be our focus, supporting the social emotional needs of our students, giving our students the tools that they need to heal, giving them the tools that they need to make their academic recovery.
Clearly, the state budget last year and the proposed budget this year make significant investments in professional development opportunities, expanded learning opportunities and so many other things that we think will help our students.
And not to mention that last year's budget does provide for us more resources to address hate directly, because we know that education is a tool in addressing hate.
Education can help to end hate.
Sadly, many young people become co-opted by things that they hear and they are they find themselves making terrible, terrible choices.
And I'm grateful that our state is implementing a 10 million dollar anti bias training program for educators in our state and that we continue to use education to end hate.
Our students are thriving in spite of these challenges.
They're doing what young people do.
They're graduating.
They're going to proms.
They're making connections in the community.
They're preparing for summer jobs.
And we find ourselves continuing to do the important work of supporting our students and our educators and our families.
Unfortunately, we have to do that still where we deal with issues like fire and and natural disaster.
And I had the opportunity to visit those who were impacted by the fires in the gun and a girl on last week.
And I want to give a big shout out to those who are working with our students and come up with some of the most creative ways to support our students.
Well, while some students were not able to attend school, school was open every day for the students impacted by the fire.
And I want to thank the folks at Wood Canyon Elementary in the Capistrano Unified School District for their work to support a relocation of these students so that students could have access to school every day.
And I want to thank the emergency team at the California Department of Education and the Office of Emergency Services for working with our families.
And it was an honor to visit and to be able to offer the family support who need relocation assistance,
housing assistance, food, water and other supports that we were able to provide.
Unfortunately, this is our new reality.
If you think about it, last year, at least 20 of our counties experienced fire or a natural disaster.
And so we've got to continue to address the impacts of climate change and to assist our families, our school families with preparedness for these opportunities.
I think our state budget does a great deal to prepare our students for many of the things that they need.
And I want to note that the midyear budget continues to place a great emphasis on recruitment of teachers and educators and a focus on more counselors.
And many of you have heard us talk about a bill that we've been working on this year with Senator McGuire, SB 1229, that we think helps us recruit 10,000 more counselors.
And I am grateful to the governor and to the state board staff and team for their work to to steer a proposal that would create an opportunity to provide grants for educators, future educators and for future counselors.
And so we're grateful to see that in this proposed budget, as well as the four hundred million dollars in funding to support literacy strategies and and multilingual literacy strategies.
We think that it's critical to as we bounce back from this moment, focus on building skill for our students.
And we know that reading is a gateway skill.
And when students learn to read, they can read to learn anything.
And so I want to thank our state board president for her partnership and our task force on reading by third grade and the members of the state board staff and board members who have participated as we continue to make sure that our children learn to read by the year 2026.
There are a number of initiatives and bills that we are sponsoring and supporting that we think will help to get us there.
But nothing I can think of more important than the investment that is in the proposed budget of literacy coaches and specialists and programs to support multilingual learners and to support our school libraries to have the resources that they need to move forward.
So we're excited about this budget as Dr.
Darlingham and noted with these record surplus that is available.
This budget proposes one hundred and twenty eight billion dollars for education and provides important resources, incredible resources.
We know that our schools are asking for help.
I think they're excited by this budget.
They're incited by the increase in funding in the base that helps them continue to address the rising cost of education.
I'm certain that they are excited about the discretionary block grant.
I think that is an amazing provision that is available to support California schools.
But we know that top of mind for our schools are things like offsetting declining enrollment.
We've seen the decline in population over the years and schools have felt that and that decline has been exacerbated by the pandemic.
So we have a lot of work to do addressing chronic absenteeism.
You know, it was pointed out to me that there is an increase in chronic absenteeism for kindergarten students.
And so we know that we have to center our work to address chronic absenteeism and of course, what we do to recruit and retain staff.
Thanks to all of you who participated in our work on the task force on reading by third grade and for all of you who participated in our task force on promoting black student achievement so that we support our students who have been impacted in the deepest ways by the opportunity gap.
We can provide a better opportunity for all of our students to remove barriers.
And as I close, I'd like to call your attention to the slide that is in front of you that highlights just a handful of the resources that California is marshaling and moving forward to help our schools build this system, build something better than what we had before.
And as I would say, transform California schools, as you can see, it centers around universal meals, being able to provide meals to every hungry child, regardless of their of their background, two meals a day, universal preschool.
I'm certain that all of you like me, we've been talking about universal preschool for decades that California can make that a reality is just incredible.
And a big shout out to the staff at the Department of Education who are working to help implement that.
You'll hear more about community schools.
These are more than just wraparound supports, but we need those wraparound supports and health and mental health and social services.
And of course, what I would call transformative supports to help change school climate, to help us reduce suspensions, to help us end the school to prison pipeline so that we are educating, not incarcerating California kids.
Professional development, more than one point two billion dollars in the Educator Effectiveness Grant, the anti bias grants that are referenced.
The governor talked has created a mental health strategy over four billion dollars.
That means that there's no wrong door to go through in accessing mental health at a time when we have the greatest needs, whether that's in your school or in your community.
And of course, expanded learning opportunities because school is more than just what happens during the school hours.
It programs before school and after school and during the summer that all told and all combined help us to build learning opportunities for California's kids.
All of these together, we think are going to be part of the strategy to help our schools build back better.
As Dr. Darling Hammond said, we must be mindful of the health challenges.
We provided five billion rapid covid tests to California schools, and we've got to be mindful about health and safety as we go forward.
But I'm grateful that California is leading with resources such as these to help us transform California schools and to build through,
build back better and build beyond the challenges that all schools in our nation face.
Madam President, this concludes my report and I submit myself to be available for any questions from you or members of the board.
Thank you so much.
We're going to move right along with item two, which is the California Community Schools Partnership Program,
approval of cohort one, the planning and implementation grantees and the approval of the lead technical assistance center contract awardee.
I suggested earlier that this has been at a rapid pace for a state agency to lift up, conceptualize and move forward a program like this.
And we're very pleased that there will be resources reaching schools as early as this summer.
The item has three recommendations for our approval, the approval of the round one planning grant awards,
the approval of the implementation grant awards and then a third recommendation on the lead technical assistance center contract.
It's a very important piece of the infrastructure moving forward that we have the technical assistance center.
And again, thanks to the team for working so tirelessly to make it happen.
The item will be presented by Superintendent Thurmond in addition to Steve Zimmer and Pete Callis and Brooklyn Williams of the State Department.
Superintendent, please begin.
Thank you, Madam President. We're excited to present this item today for board approval.
In short, we will be talking about the recommendations for for planning grants, implementation grants and technical assistance, a technical assistance lead.
Grateful to the staff at the Department of Education and the staff at the state board for the work on this.
There has been outstanding cooperation and participation.
There's been a high level of community participation.
We've had conversations with districts and charter schools about what community schools means to help California schools in this moment.
You'll hear from a number of our staff.
First and foremost, Steve Zimmer, who has been working on the community school strategy pretty much since the beginning.
He's formally come on board at the California Department of Education as one of our deputy superintendents.
You'll also hear from Brooklyn Williams, who is a senior advisor here at the Department of Education and who has worked on community schools extensively in the community and the field.
I would also acknowledge Abel Guian, who you all may hear from today, who has joined us as a deputy superintendent of operations and administration branch.
Mr. Guian has been working on a number of programs to help the physical development of our schools.
And I would note that, among other things, in the course of his career, he's helped to generate two billion dollars for school maintenance and construction,
something that is also featured in this proposed budget and something of great interest to many of our schools.
And so with that framing, I'll turn it over with the deputy superintendent, Steve Zimmer, to take us into the presentation.
Members of the board, it is a true honor to share our progress towards actualizing the promise of community schools in California.
I first want to thank Superintendent Thurman for his justice driven vision to create the California Community Schools Partnership Program as a school transformation initiative throughout our state,
beginning in communities that have suffered the consequences of health, economic and educational disparities.
I also want to thank, sincerely thank, the board president, the executive director of the state board, and the whole of the SBE staff,
especially Rigel and Jessica, for their seamless partnership throughout this process.
We're getting to meet each other in person for the first time today.
I heard there was some curiosity about what I actually looked like in person.
I encourage everybody to manage their expectations.
I also want to give a huge thanks to our CDE team, Deanna Niebuhr, Lisa Reimers, and Pete Callis, who you'll hear from later today.
They, together with the SBE staff, have stayed up countless nights and worked endless weekends,
really giving their heart and soul to get us to the finish line and to what I believe is the right finish line.
And finally, I want to thank each of you.
The support of the state board has allowed us to begin to actualize an historic moment for community schools.
As a school transformation program under a bold and justice-driven framework, which you approved in January,
we believe this holds game-changing possibilities for students, their families, and our schools across the state.
Thank you. Thank each of you.
Board members, we come to you today to ask for your confirmation of our recommendations
for the initial round of the California Community Schools Partnership Program Planning Grants,
Implementation Grants, and the Lead Technical Assistance Contract.
Today, you'll hear from myself, our division director, Pete Callis, and later, Brooklyn Williams,
who is a senior advisor to the superintendent.
As division director Callis will outline in a few moments,
we seek your approval to allocate close to $80 million to schools, LEAs, and amazing partnership
that we are coming to you to recommend to lead the critical technical assistance design for our state.
As we discussed in the January board meeting, the California Community Schools Partnership Program
seeks to transform relationships that support learning,
which will in turn transform outcomes for our students, their families, and entire school communities.
Further, we understand that this transformational model is rooted in and guided by an equity mission
that recognizes the students, families, and communities who have been most marginalized and oppressed
by intentional disparities, both in and within our educational system,
be the first engaged by this initiative that seeks to address those inequities.
I'm from LA, so I know better than to give away our best line in the trailer,
but know that we in CDE are deeply humbled by the equity-driven prioritization of schools and communities
where the need is greatest and assets have not been elevated for far too long.
In order to understand the depth and reach of this moment, we'll look back at our process
and the journey that we have been on since the legislature passed the California Community Schools Partnership Act
and the resulting program was codified and funded as part of the Budget Act of 2021
and the governor's budget of that same year.
I will take us through a few slides that review this journey and then I'll hand it over to Pete Callis,
who will discuss our RFA process and report our results.
We're proud of these recommendations and hopeful that this board will concur
and we are excited to move forward with the full launch of this program in the 2022-23 school year.
These are the recommendations for SBE approval.
CDE recommends that SBE approve the CCSP Round 1 planning grants.
You have the attached list of approved applicants.
CDE further recommends that the SBE confirm the CCSP Round 1 implementation grants.
You also have the list of approved applicants and I'm proud to say the long list of individual school sites recommended for funding.
In approving this implementation grant recommendation, CDE requests SBE authorize CDE to fund
first round implementation grants to meet the statutory priority of funding schools with over 80% unduplicated students enrolled.
And finally, CDE recommends that the SBE confirm CDE's lead technical assistance center contract award recommendation.
A bit of an overview, in 2021, the legislature allocated over $3 billion for the CCSPP to establish new and expand existing community schools
through the school year of ending in June 2028.
It includes grants to LEAs and technical assistance centers.
The CCSP requires the state board to approve an administration plan and application process for the program, which happened in November.
All LEA grantees and technical assistance program and awardees and receive annual updates from the CDE.
We're doing the second of that today.
Reminder planning grants.
This was 10% of the overall funding.
There are two rounds, the first of which we will present for approval today.
These will be for the 2021, 21, 22, 23 program year.
These funds can be spent over a two year grant period, but LEAs only receive one time grant of $200,000 per qualifying LEA.
And the planning grants must go to LEAs with no existing community schools.
We have implementation grants.
The process is up to 70% of the total funding, over $2 billion.
There are multiple rounds going through 21, 22, through the 27, 28 program year.
It is a five year grant period with annual grants up to $500,000 per school site.
People go through this with you.
LEAs, I'm sorry, implementation grants are for LEAs with existing community schools.
Technical assistance centers were also allocated for funds for contracts with LEAs to create statute,
instruct us to create a minimum of five regional technical assistance centers.
In October, we provided this board with an informational memorandum with an introduction to our community schools model and an overview of the CCSPP.
Then in November of 2021, the board approved the CCSPP proposed application process and administrative plan.
Thank you again for that.
Then in January of 2022, the board adapted the framework as the guiding document for the implementation of the CCSPP,
approved also an amendment to our application and administration plan to establish a lead tech in the lead technical assistance center in the winter of 22
and an RFA for regional technical assistance centers later in this calendar year.
I do want to spend a moment talking again about the framework,
which has been really received in the field and community as a guiding document.
And thank you again for your embrace and support of this framework.
The framework expanded what is the nationally accepted four pillars of community schools to include four key conditions for learning,
four key cornerstone commitments, four key proven practices and four key roles.
And I want to, particularly in light of the superintendent's powerful invocation of recent events in his introduction,
I want to remind us of the four cornerstone commitments which you so embraced and approved in January.
A commitment to an assets driven and strength based practice in our community schools,
a commitment to racially just and restorative school climates in our community schools,
a commitment to powerful, culturally proficient and relevant instruction in our community schools,
and a commitment to shared decision making and participatory practices in our community schools.
I thank you again for approving this guiding document for the field.
We engaged in and shared with you both in November and January now share again.
We engaged with extensive outreach that really informed both the framework and guided our entire RFA process.
There were regional forums held in November and December throughout the state.
Over 500 interest holders, students, families, school staff and community members attended the sessions.
Yes, they included presentations, but they mostly included opportunities for attendees to offer their vision and their priorities.
And I must say their experiences, their stories, their testimonies.
And this really informed our process at every stage.
We also offered what we called office hours.
They became really meetings over January, February, March.
It was probably more than 12, but at least 12 meetings with interest holder groups.
And we held five largely attended webinars, extensive information sessions that I still feel like I'm recovering from sometimes
with potential applicants for each of the RFAs.
I'm going to now turn it over to Division Director Pete Callis, who will take you through the each of the grant awards that we're going to ask for your support with today.
And bringing Pete Callis up here, I just I just want to extend to Pete, his entire team, our great thanks for the work that they've done that they have done night and day to get this across the finish line.
He. Madam President, as Mr. Callis comes, I would also like to acknowledge him for his work and the work of the entire division on the community schools work.
And Madam President, with your approval, I will be stepping out and Chief Deputy Nicely will join us on the dais.
I've also been summoned to give testimony in Senate Education Budget Subcommittee one.
And one of the topics will be on community schools and what's in the budget.
So if the chief deputy superintendent will take over for me. Thank you.
All right. Good morning, President Darling-Hammond and board members.
The Career College Transition Division team developed a streamlined needs based application process for the planning grants and implementation grants.
The reading scoring team adhered to a multi-section rubric as we went through the scoring process for both of the grant programs.
The Planning Grant RFA was released on March 1st. We had two hundred and three complete applications submitted.
The total funding request was just over forty one and a half million dollars.
The breakdown of the LEA's for the two hundred and three applications, there were 100 school districts, fifteen county offices of education,
eighty seven charter schools and one joint powers authority.
The results of the round one planning grant reading and scoring process included one hundred and ninety two LEA's recommended for planning grant awards.
The total of the funding for the planning grant awards was thirty eight million two hundred thousand one hundred and twenty two dollars.
This leaves us just over two hundred and fifty nine million dollars for round two planning grant applications.
CDE will distribute planning grant award notifications so that the grantees can begin their community school planning in the twenty two,
twenty three school year right before July one.
Applicants that were not recommended for planning grant funding did not meet the minimum qualification guidelines that are in statute.
We will continue to provide funding for the planning grant awards for the twenty three school year right before July one.
Moving on to the implementation grants again, we utilize a streamlined needs based application process.
The implementation grant RFA was released on March 11th, ten days after the Planning Grant RFA, we received ninety complete applications.
The total of the funding for the planning grant applications was fifty nine school districts, eleven county offices of education and twenty charter schools.
For implementation grant allocations, they're all based on student need and school site enrollment.
It was broken down into four categories, small districts, small LEA's up to four hundred students and then small to medium four hundred and one to a thousand students,
medium to large one thousand and one to two thousand students.
And then we had the large category of two thousand and one plus students.
The results of the round one implementation grant reading and scoring process included seventy six LEA's in twenty nine of our fifty eight counties across the state were
recommended for implementation grant award supporting four hundred and fifty eight individual school sites.
The total of the fund for funding for implementation grant awards is six hundred and eleven million dollars, six hundred and eleven million eighty seven thousand five hundred dollars,
which is about two hundred and eleven million more than what we were planning on.
CD will distribute the implementation grant award notification so these LEA's can get started right away on their planning and implementation work going forward right at the beginning of the twenty two,
twenty three school year applicants that were not recommended for an implementation grant did not meet the statutory priorities.
The statutory priority we are referring to is the grant making priority for schools serving an unduplicated pupil count of eighty percent or higher.
The department made the decision to adhere to the statutory priority in the implementation grant round one to ensure that we retain sufficient funds for all planning grantees to receive implementation grants as required by statute.
To be clear, a denial in the initial round of funding does not mean that LEA's would never receive funding for schools serving fewer than eighty percent high need students.
We encourage LEA's to apply in subsequent rounds for implementation grants.
There is approximately one point four million one point four billion dollars remaining in the for future implementation grants.
As Mr. Zimmer mentioned earlier, there was an amendment to the program administration plan with the addition of a lead technical assistance center.
The lead technical assistance center responsibilities will include to build content and overarching methodology for technical assistance, build a developmental implementation to articulate community school implementation for all of our sites that receive implementation grants along with planning grants, facilitate community of practice among the regional technical assistance centers, which will have the RFA out for those later this year, coordinate and maximize areas of expertise.
Among the regional technical assistance centers, there will be a subsequent RFA for the regional tax following here in twenty twenty two.
So in contrast to the RFA process for planning implementation grants, the lead technical assistance center RFA was extremely rigorous with many questions that delved into each applicant's extensive expertise.
And experience in supporting community schools and school improvement. The entire scoring rubric was included in the posted RFA.
The department released the lead technical assistance center RFA on March 30th CDE received for highly competitive applications for the lead tech.
Total funding for the lead technical assistance center is twenty four million dollars over six years. The application submitted were from four county offices of education.
The readers adhere to the posted rubric for the scoring of applications, which consisted of multiple sections and multiple prongs to each section.
The department is very excited to announce the selection of Alameda County Office of Education as a lead technical assistance center for the California Community Schools Partnership Program grantees and the five regional technical assistance centers.
They currently lead the Alameda County Community Exemplary Schools for School Success Consortium, which leverages the funding for the RFA.
The department is very excited to announce the selection of the Alameda County Exemplary Schools for School Success Consortium, which leverages the 2020 CCSPP grant to serve nearly two thousand students at five high need schools this coupled with their demonstrated leadership and expanded learning and the statewide system of support positions them well to be up and running quickly to offer technical assistance to grantees alongside their outstanding partners.
As you know, the statute gave priority to applicants for the technical assistance centers who partnered with Institutes of Higher Learning or nonprofit community based partners. Alameda County Office of Education's application included both the UCLA Center for Community Schooling.
We'll co lead the effort with the Alameda County Office of Education. The center has over 15 years of experience supporting community schools and as a university initiative plays a unique role with their many community school partners offering stability, research capabilities, teaching and service activities.
Their co leadership is a lead technical assistance center and ability to leverage their years of experience will help to inform the work of our planning and implementation grantees across the state.
As the framework points out, there are a small number of proven practices that all California community schools should adopt and adapt to meet the needs of their schools.
One of these is to align and integrate with education, justice and equity initiatives at the district and site level. So we're pleased that another partner organization for Alameda County Office of Education is Californians for Justice.
Californians for Justice is a statewide grassroots organization with over 25 years of experience with building the power of youth and communities of color.
The establishment of shared decision making structures, processes and protocols are essential to successful planning and implementation of community schools.
So we're pleased to announce that Alameda County Office of Education has included the National Education Association as a partner with a decade of community school implementation nationwide.
They're currently supporting over a thousand schools in 39 of our states.
The department is excited to work with Alameda County Office of Education with assisting and offering technical assistance to both current and future CCSPP grantees on their journey into developing a highly successful community school system.
Thank you and I'd like to pass the presentation back to Mr. Zimmer.
Thank you so much, Pete. As I said before, we literally could not have done this without Pete and his division.
These RFAs have been completed with expertise, commitment and care and we thank Pete and thank his division.
Before I take us through next steps, board members, I would like to introduce the mayor's senior advisor, Brooklyn Williams.
I came to know Brooklyn's work in the Bay Area, particularly around freedom schools.
Brooklyn is going and thrilled that she's part of our team as the superintendent's senior advisor.
She's going to share a little bit about her experience in implementing community schools.
All right. Good morning, everyone. Good morning, board.
Thank you for your service to the students, families and educators of California.
My name is Brooklyn Williams and I am the new senior advisor to Superintendent Thurman.
It is an honor to be with you this morning.
I decided to join the California Department of Education because of my passion and belief in many of the initiatives Superintendent Thurman is focusing on.
My lived experience working in schools over the last 25 years has taught me one of the most important of those initiatives is the advancement of community schools.
Indeed, the community schools model is the glue that holds all school transformation strategies together.
I helped build a community school from the ground up during my time working at a continuation school in Oakland during the early 2000s.
At the time we didn't know we were building what became known as a community school.
We were just trying to meet the needs of our students in order to keep them in school and on the path towards graduation.
Our teachers, administrators and classified staff were trying to serve as social workers, case managers, housing navigators, mental health practitioners and a whole host of other roles that they didn't have the training or capacity to do consistently.
We had recruited a talented team of teachers, but we could see that they were on the path to burnout while trying to play a multitude of roles for one of the most vulnerable student populations in our district.
We needed reinforcements and we needed them badly.
Meanwhile, our students often miss school to run around town trying to access important services.
Many students were not able to access services due to transportation barriers or having family responsibilities and other competing responsibilities.
For our students impacted by the criminal legal system, not attending counseling appointments or substance abuse prevention programs and other court ordered activities could mean violating their probation and returning to detention.
We knew we had to do something to stop the unhealthy cycle of our staff and students that they were caught in.
We started with engaging our students and launching a paid student leadership internship program.
Our student leaders suggested we offer substance abuse intervention services on campus as well as conflict resolution.
The student leaders learned de-escalation and peer mediation skills and we partnered with them to reduce conflicts and the potential for violence on and off our campus.
After securing the first two services on campus, we went on to partner with community based organizations and public agencies who provided wellness services, case management, legal services and support for our gang impacted students.
This was made much easier by the fact that our district launched a full service community school initiative and we were provided with the designated staff to help provide technical assistance and establish a coordinated services team.
Due to our collaborative efforts, our school became a one stop shop for our students to get many of their needs met.
As a result, we saw our attendance rates improve, our graduation rates go up, suspension rates go down and our staff turnover reduced.
We transformed our school climate and culture by creating a school that focused on nurturing transformative relationships.
School was no longer a transactional place where students came to try and earn their diploma in exchange for attending class and turning in assignments.
But instead, school was a place where our students' whole humanity was seen.
They felt safe and were able to heal and grow and most importantly learn.
I experienced firsthand how community schools can literally save our students' lives and interrupt the school to prison pipeline.
The saying goes, it takes a village to raise a child.
Well, community schools embraces this truth and acknowledges that schools are the center of that village and we need to raise the whole child.
I look forward to partnering with you, my CDE colleagues and districts throughout our state to advance community schools as we embark on this historic opportunity to mitigate the impact of COVID-19,
systemic inequities, break unhealthy generational cycles and reimagine the future of learning for students and families in California.
Thank you for allowing me the time to share my experience and I will now turn it back to Deputy Superintendent Steve Semer.
Thank you so much, Brooklyn. Thank you for grounding us, for reminding us the potential and the power for what it means to transform relationships at a school site.
It's not just about academic outcomes, as we know.
And we thank you for the experience, the wisdom and the voices of our students and our families that you will continue to bring to us in this collaborative process.
Board members, I want to take you through our next key steps as we move forward from today.
And then myself and the team will be here to answer and address any questions that you might have.
And I'm going to go through this and try not to be overwhelmed by what I'm going to share with you.
After today's vote, our team will immediately turn our attention to the launching of our planning and implementation grant cohorts and ensuring that we have the technical assistance in place and to not only make sure that each awardee has a successful launch,
but their community school journey is supported at every step along the way to these transformed relationships and these transformed outcomes.
So we are we are first going to, of course, you know, notify all of our officially notify all of our round one planning and implementation grant awardees.
We are going to execute contracts and distribute funds to the approved planning and planning and implementation grant awardees.
We are going to convene webinars, which will serve as initial convenings for the planning and implementation grant cohorts.
We will execute the contract for the lead technical assistance center awardee and build out the timeline for technical the technical assistance design.
We will release the RFA for the regional technical assistance centers and complete that RFA competitive process on a timeline that allows for us to present recommended awardees to this board at your September meeting.
And complete that RFA competitive process on a timeline that allows for us to present recommended awardees to this board at your September meeting.
We will develop in consultation with the lead technical assistance center awardee and in collaboration with state board staff, an interim technical assistance strategy that will provide necessary guidance for successful program launch for our awardees.
As well as building a bridge to the comprehensive technical assistance that will be developed by the lead technical assistance center and will be implemented through the regional technical assistance center design.
All of these initial next steps will be completed or fully engaged by June 30.
In addition, I want to share with you that we know as much as we are coming to you in some ways in celebration of this process, we know that we have a lot to learn.
We know that we have a lot to reflect upon.
And for those of us as Brooklyn, Brooklyn mentioned who have been doing community schools work way, way before we even knew that term.
We know that we learn from every process.
We have to open our hearts and our minds to our own learning as we continue to develop.
And so we're going to dive deep and analyze the round one planning grant and implementation grant data to see what we have to celebrate and elevate, but also to identify community school deserts.
What are the sections of our state where we did not receive applications and figure out how we are intentional about an outreach and engagement plan during the round two RFA processes.
We, we know that we need to more deeply engage with our early childhood community.
We, we know that we prioritize this for LEAs, but we know that there is an entire ecosystem in our early childhood community that extends well beyond LEAs.
And we know that this is a place of growth and we know that this needs to be a place of focus as we move forward.
We will also name and seat and launch the, the superintendent's statewide advisory board for the California Community Schools Partnership Program.
And we will name and seat and launch a, a youth council as well for, for the CCSPP.
And last, we will, we will develop a comprehensive outreach plan for round two of the planning and implementation grants and connected to in your board packet, there should be a revised timeline, overall timeline for our program.
I, I want to conclude again by thanking you, thanking the superintendent, the governor, the legislature, all the members of our, of our team and just to reference both the superintendent's opening remarks and the board president's opening remarks.
Our hearts are heavy this week.
And we, we feel deeply pain and loss, both of the horrible incidents of violence and hate that were referenced, but also of the demarcation point of 1 million lives lost to COVID.
And as the board president said, those of us who have lost folks personally in our family feel it very, very deeply.
We also know that so many of our students, especially those in the schools that we are funding in this first round of implementation grants have felt the disproportional impacts of COVID devastating impacts.
I don't think we fully have our heads wrapped around.
We know in our hearts that this program is an important step towards the type of change in investment that will lead to not only healing, but transformation.
We thank you for your consideration of these recommendations today. We thank you for your partnership. And I look forward to answering any and all questions that you have. Thank you. I'm present.
Thank you very much. And we're going to ask for the public comment slide so we can queue up.
I think I have it on here. I'm a rookie.
There we go.
Thank you so much.
And thanks for that wonderful presentation.
Members of the public who wish to provide comment on this item may do so by calling the telephone number and using the access code provided on the slide that is shown now.
While we're waiting for members of the public to call in, I want to ask member Escobedo if he has any initial comments.
And then we will see if there are clarifying questions before we go to public comment.
Again, I want to commend, you know, CDE and SBE for just a Herculean effort in starting. We just started. It's a great beginning.
You got to see the significant list and the planning as well as the implementation.
I mean, the effects that we're going to have statewide is going to be incredible.
And I hope we begin to also measure the incredible effects of this plan down the road because we have many challenges.
We know about chronic absenteeism has, I believe, doubled in California and in many other states.
I do believe we have, you know, how do we activate engagement?
How do we create that relevance, relevancy and connectiveness, you know, for our students in the schools that they go to is going to be very critical.
And I know this this program, whether you're planning or implementing, is going to do that.
And I look forward to the effects of this of this amazing opportunity for our state and amazing opportunity for our students and families and us to learn, you know,
from from this whole grant process that will take in effect what the next eight years. Is that correct?
And again, what a great beginning, a real time for celebration and the timing as you could have been done last year, but the timing couldn't be better.
I mean, couldn't be better. The need is there. Thank you.
And I echo a member Escobedo's gratitude to the department. I think that there's a we're off to a very good start.
I'm gratified that the department intentionally streamlined the application for LEAs and weighted it towards the unique needs of each of the LEA student bodies.
The legislature, the board, the department are aligned that this is an equity initiative and wherever LEAs are in their community schools implementation,
they will be supported by robust technical assistance aligned to the community schools framework,
which is going to be a critical kind of linchpin in the process. I did want to ask one clarifying question.
I want to see if there are any other clarifying questions from the board, then we'll go to public comments.
So thank you very much, Steve. In terms of the regional technical assistance center process that will follow.
Can you clarify when that is likely to come back to the to the board?
It will. It will come back in September. Thank you very much for a recommendation.
You are our expeditious process here. Are there any clarifying questions? If there are any discussion questions, we'll save those to later. Yes.
Yes, thank you. It's a monumental process and very exciting for the whole state of California.
One clarifying question is on the planning grants. If a I guess I could take up to two years with the planning phase.
If if an LEA decides that it only takes one year, can they pull the trigger and apply for an implementation grant earlier in the process?
Absolutely. It's actually our anticipation that most will apply for the implementation grant after one year.
It's it's just a two year window where they can spend spend that money. Thank you.
Any other clarifying questions at this moment? I'm so used to looking on the Zoom screen for the little participant hands.
They're like real hands going up. I don't know what to do with this.
Member Rodriguez, then I'll come to member Roscoe Gonzalez and then I'll come around to the other side. Thank you.
So my my question is, will the dashboards at community schools be different?
Will there be like different criteria that will be added, an indication when we look at that data of any changes?
Well, that's a that's a great question. And it's not a question I have an answer to right right now.
But I think it's something that that we do need to consider because as we spoke about both in in as it relates to community schools,
but also as it relates to some of our other key initiatives, social emotional learning, for example,
looking at how we build in indicators into the dashboard is certainly something that I think that we need to prioritize and consider.
So I appreciate the question. I don't have an answer yet, but it's something that's certainly on our minds.
We'll find some way that there's some analytics that we can look at. I'm quite sure.
I think the next person was member Roscoe Gonzalez.
Did you also have your hand up?
You did. Yeah.
OK, I just had a question about this is a great beginning also to activate engagement to reach students of diverse backgrounds.
My question is, what is the plan for outreach the districts that qualify for the planning grant but didn't apply?
I heard you said that you had some things in process for that.
You know, what I what I said and what I want to reiterate is we are concerned about that and we we need to we need to look deeper into why districts that qualified
LEAs that qualified did not participate in this process this spring.
I can tell you anecdotally that we've heard from a lot of districts that said this was the hardest year that we've ever had and that we're we want to do this, but we just couldn't do one more thing this spring.
And we want to kind of go through by kind of a more intentional process.
So that's one of the things that we've heard.
But I want to be cautious in kind of laying out a plan before we really look deep into, you know, kind of where those those deserts are where those gaps are.
I think we may need to do we may need to have a very multifaceted outreach strategy because I think that the reasons why LEAs might not have applied in some parts of our state may be different than in other parts of the state.
So we look forward to reporting back to you on that in September when we come with the Regional Technical Assistance Center grants.
Thank you.
Member Lewis.
Just back to the interim technical assistance that districts will be provided.
Is that from would that be from Alameda County and does the two questions and does the June 30th deadline that you mentioned or timeframe for all of the assistance to be put in place?
Does that include the RFA for the regional techs?
It does. It does. We want to have that process launched before June 30th. That's our internal, you know, goal and timeline.
And I want just as I did with the previous question, we are going to gather ourselves after today's meeting.
We know that there is going to be a gap in time between when we're going to have this contract executed, hopefully with the approval of the board today.
And that contract execution as I as I knew very well from my times in L.A. USD, but I've also learned in my few months here at CD, contract execution does not always match the school calendar.
And so we know that we have we're going to have this gap period.
And so what we intend to do is it's really to regather ourselves, our team, the state board staff team, also our partners from West Ed who have been providing technical assistance to the the initial grant that was that was offered in 2020 and develop a plan to to make sure that we have that baseline technical assistance in place to help with the the launching of both plans.
Of both planning grants and implementation grants. And as I said, I know this is kind of a general term, but the idea is to build a bridge to the comprehensive the comprehensive technical assistance to to address your question on the involvement of Alameda County.
I can't speak specifically to that as we're going as we're going to be executing a contract, hopefully after the approval today.
But it's certainly my hope that that that that they would be involved, at least in a consult consultatory way, because we want whatever bridge we build to align with the technique, the comprehensive technical assistance they're going to be developing.
I hope that begins to address the question.
I do appreciate the the attention to that interim technical assistance before the regional support is on the ground because I know schools, everybody's excited about community schools and the value that they're going to bring.
And I know if I'm at a school site and I've got a planning implementation grant I'm wanting to be off and running so I do appreciate the detail and the attention to providing that interim assistance until those regional techs are.
Thank you. Thank you for remember this very much on our minds. Thank you.
Right. I think we're going to, we have, I believe, one in person comment which we'll take first and then we'll go to public comment on the telephone line where we have quite a number of people lined up ready to call in, please.
Make your way forward and back here.
Make your way a little bit forward but not all the way to the front.
And we encourage you to state your name and affiliation for the record.
No, I don't think the mic is turned up yet.
Right. The first one through the tunnel always gets bloody Is that correct.
Good morning everybody. It's so nice to see you in person.
My name is Michael Juba, and I am a classroom teacher representing the California Teachers Association.
CTA really does appreciate the impressive work that CD and SBE and helping to the state to arrive at this moment to help move nearly $3 billion investment from statute to reality has really been a tremendous undertaking to truly support this work.
CTA believes that CD and SBE should limit the number of regional TACs to five.
This is necessary to ensure the high quality TAs across the state, and to not dilute the funding and targeting approval for the July SBE meeting makes practical sense for them to be up and running in the fall.
The RFA and the regional TACs must be explicit that all technical assistance must be grounded in the California Community Schools framework and specifically aligned with the four pillars in alignment with the lead TAC.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you very much.
And with that, I believe I can move to the line on the phone line.
Is that right?
Yeah.
Okay, so for those who are calling in, we encourage you to please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Remember to turn down the speaker volume of your computer.
If you are following the live feed, speakers will be limited to one minute each and where speakers require interpretation, two minutes will be provided.
Okay, we currently have 19 people in the callers in a queue for public comment.
I will open the phone line now.
State Board of Education, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller with the last four digits ending in 7570, you are live.
Please start your comments now.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Caller ending with the number 5292, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
State Board of Education, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
I want to echo President Darling-Hammond,
and members Cabello's comments
about this being a Herculean effort accomplished by the state
to create in such a great amount of time
this transformative approach
known as the Community Schools Partnership Program.
Our ask is for the State Board of Education
and the State Board of Education
to produce development in the community schools partnership program.
Our ask is for the State Board of Education
to provide clear accountability
and consistent technical assistance
strengthen this program.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state
your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
My name is Rosario Hernandez and I am community liaison with True North Organizing Network
in Humboldt County and a member of the California Partnership for the Future Learning.
The California Partnership is a statewide alliance of community organizing advocacy
groups led by Advancement Project California, Californians for Justice, Peco California
Education for Liberation and Advocates.
With the support of community coalition, inner city struggle and over a dozen graduate research
and philanthropic partners, we center the voices leadership of black, indigenous and
brown students, families and communities of color across the state to advance a shared
vision of transformational, racially just, relationship centered community schools.
The California Partnership supported families, students and educators to help this three
billion dollar community schools grant program.
We know that transformation happens when students, families, community and educators are authentic
partners.
It takes all of us to create community schools.
Today you'll be hearing from members of our network about how important this opportunity
for school transformation is for us as students, families and community leaders.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Time starts now.
Good morning.
Erin Aftey with Public Advocates and the California Partnership for the Future of Learning.
We'd like to thank CDE and the board for listening to youth, families and educators in the community
schools grant design and implementation.
We see many of our community's recommendations reflected in the framework, grant RFAs and
the program's goals and requirements.
We're also thrilled to see many of these provisions included and strengthened in the May revision
trailer bill, along with an additional one and a half billion dollar proposed investment
to ensure that every eligible high need school in the state can become a racially just relationship
centered community school.
We strongly believe that the state LEAs, schools and technical assistance centers must work
together to ensure that schools and districts authentically share power and decision making
with directly impacted students, families and educators and leverage the expertise of
their community partners in co-creating schools.
Doing so will transform our schools, close racialized achievement gaps and better serve
the social, emotional and behavioral health needs of our school communities.
Thank you.
Next caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning, everybody.
My name is Prida Romero.
I am a youth organizer with ICUC in the eastern Cotilla Valley and a member of California
Partnership as well as part of the Pico California Education for Liberation.
Community schools are transformative because they value and leverage the expertise of our
communities.
That is why we fully support the governor's proposed trailer bill language which restricts
community school guarantees from using funds on committed disciplinary practices like police
and officers that harm students of color.
We also advocate for mental health resources as kids navigate being reintegrated into in
person schooling and deal with unprecedented adversities.
Transformation happens with students, families, communities and educators are authentic partners.
It takes all of us to create rationally just relationship centered community schools.
We urge you to provide leadership to support districts and schools to live up to the framework
commitments and shared power and decision making.
Thank you.
Next caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning, board members.
My name is Karn Tatang with California for Justice and the California Partnership for
the Future of Learning.
I want to thank you and the team at CDE for y'all's work on community schools and centering
the voices of students and families in the rollout of community schools.
At CFJ and in the partnership, as we work towards this long-term vision of school transformation,
we believe that the people most impacted by an issue should be the ones creating the solutions
and the come to schools that means students and families.
That's why it's so important that grantees have a plan to use an existing or create a
decision-making community school team that includes students, families, educators, and
community-based organizations.
We're so excited to see that the governor agrees and included this in the proposed grant
priority criteria for future rounds of grants.
Thank y'all.
Thank you.
Next caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
My name is Day Sun with the Advancement Project California and a member of the California
Partnership.
We appreciate the SE and CDE's commitment to local transparency and accountability,
both integral to school transformation.
LEAs should annually present their community schools plan, including data outcomes from
the prior year at the school and district level, such as the local advisory committees
and at school board meetings, to remain eligible for grant funding.
We're excited to see this annual public presentation included in the statute as a program requirement
and think it should apply to planning grant awardees.
In LA Unified, we've seen the power of historically marginalized communities engaging the district
to ensure equity for $700 million allocated by the Student Equity Needs Index.
When students and families are brought to the table with access to information around
dollars, actions, plans, and other key decisions facing schools, they can better dialogue and
share their expertise around the needed steps to better outcomes for low-income students
and students of color.
Transformation happens when students, families, communities, and educators are authentic partners.
It takes all of us to create racially just, relationship-centered community schools.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, good morning.
My name is Ed Olsevo.
I'm a youth organizer with Inland Congregations United for Change and a member of FICO California's
Education for Liberation.
The community schools framework commitment to racially just and restorative school climate
can only be realized by rejecting school hardening and pushing out practices that criminalize
and marginalize students.
As a former high school educator here in the Inland Empire, I have witnessed how heavily
policed schools serving students of color are.
I've seen how our students are criminalized and unjustly pushed into the school discipline
pipeline because they're deemed a perceived threat by school security or even their teachers.
It's imperative that our school districts begin to focus on replacing punitive discipline
with racially just and restorative practices into the pipeline.
Transformation happens in students, families, community, and educators are authentic partners.
It takes all of us to create racially just, relationship-centered community schools.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning, President Darning-Hammond and board members.
My name is Maritza Benmudez, and I am a community organizer with Orange County Congregation
Community Organization and a parent leader at the Anaheim Union High School District
and Anaheim Elementary School District in the city of Anaheim and a member of the California
Partnership.
I want to celebrate this moment and opportunity for my school's transformation as both of
the districts that my children attend receive community school grants.
And I can proudly say that I was part of the grant writing process with Anaheim Union High
School District.
For my schools, receiving the community school grant will mean so many things, but most importantly
to me and my community, it will let us have a voice and an active seat at the table.
Building authentic relationships between students, families, educators, and community partners
is key to the success of a transformational change that will benefit our community.
I want to end by highlighting that transformation happens when students, families, communities,
and educators are authentic partners.
It takes all of us to create racially just relationship centers, community schools.
And I also want to thank the Anaheim Union High School District for their leadership
and leading the way for the community schools model in our city.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Assalamu alaikum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.
My name is Maryam Abdi, and I'm a parent leader with the Pacific California Education
for Literation in Auckland and a member of the California Foundation.
We are excited to see many of our community priorities from the regional core uplifted
in the community school framework and program requirements.
Many of the early speaking parents I know share similar concerns about how to raise
our children so they can be close to their culture and at the same time be included in
the school community.
When we participated in the forum last December, we shared that our school needs to be responsive
to our needs.
We want our children and all the students to have equitable access to quality teaching
and learning.
And that's why we must value and leverage the expertise of our community and community
organization to partner with diverse families, students, and educators.
It takes all of us to create a relatively just relationship between some community schools.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
We'll need two minutes with a Spanish speaker with interpretation.
Okay, no problem.
Thank you.
My name is Celvia and I am a mom in the Sacramento School District and a member of the California
Partnership.
For my school, receiving subsidies for this community school means that students and
families can receive mental health support to receive this support that they need so much.
In my school, building authentic relationships between students, families, educators, and
community partners is the key to success.
My name is Celvia and I'm a parent on Sacramento School District.
I'm a member of the California Partnership for the schools.
Receiving this community school grant will mean that students and families will be able
to receive the support that they need.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
This grant will mean that students and families will be able to receive more mental health
support.
They will be able to receive the support they so badly need.
At my school, building authentic relationships between students, families, and educators
and community partners is the key to success.
The schools must be designed with parents and students and the table to decide how the
dollars are going to spend.
This is a great opportunity.
I want to see our needs represented and how the money will be spent.
I'm very happy to celebrate the effort that we all made.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi.
We'll need two minutes for a monolingual speaker with interpretation and an additional
minute for the interpreter who's also an organizer to provide your testimony.
Okay.
Thank you.
Please proceed with your comments.
Go ahead.
Okay.
She is.
Oh yeah,
I'm a little hurt.
But it did not sit on the
the
plenary itself and
on the
but now
in number that
california
prime jeep
below that meant in
labor highlight the
proreso
the
proper a
cover in our car
REE
refrain
bon ln
.
Well the
community
I don't know if it's going to be in the future.
My name is Alma Chavez.
I am a parent leader in Fullerton, California with OCO, Pico California Education for Liberation
and a member of the California Partnership.
We fully support the language in the governor's proposed bill that restricts community schools
grantees from using funds on punitive disciplinary practices such as police and resource officers
who harm students of color.
As a parent, I hope that our schools are a place of support and not a place of punishment
and trauma.
Transformation happens when students, families, and community and educators are authentic
partners.
It takes all of us to create racially judged relationships in our community schools.
Thank you.
My name is Karen Alvarado and I am lead organizer with OCO, that's Orange County Congregation
Community Organization at Pico California Education for Liberation Federation down in
Orange County and a member of the California Partnership for the Future of Learning.
The community school framework commitment to racially just and restorative school climates
can only be realized by rejecting school harnany and push out practices that criminalize and
marginalize students, caregivers, and their communities.
As an organizer, I have seen the racial disparities in our schools that hurt students, families,
and communities and we all now have an opportunity to transform and heal.
So thank you so much for that and transformation happens when students, families, communities,
and educators are authentic partners and it takes all of us to create racially just relationships
in our schools.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
We have one minute.
Your time starts now.
We'll need two minutes for a monolingual speaker with interpretation and then an additional
one minute for the interpreter who is also an organizer to provide testimony.
Okay, no problem.
Please proceed.
My name is Gabriela Silva, United Fathers, BAC in Salinas, in the County of Monterrey.
I am an organizer and a mother leader.
The experience with our community is to ensure that the districts will include the most impacted
families of ethnic languages and diverse minorities in the community.
We want transparency in the process without limiting parents and students to be part of
the process and ensure that the pressure of you brings transparency and authentic involvement.
For us it is very important that you listen to us for the future of our young people.
The transformation happens when students, families, communities, and educators are authentic
partners for the success of all generations.
Thank you.
My name is Gabriela Silva, United Fathers, BAC in Salinas, in Monterrey County.
I'm an organizer and a parent leader.
Our experience of the community has been ensuring that districts include the entire community
in decisions, especially the most impacted families of diverse languages, ethnicities,
and races.
We want transparency in the processes without limiting parents and students in being part
of the process.
We want to ensure that your pressure brings transparency and authentic involvement.
For us and for the future of our young people, it is very important that they listen to us.
Transformation happens when students, families, communities, and educators are authentic partners
for the success of every generation.
Thank you.
Now I will give my testimony.
My name is Katie Nunez-Adler, I'm a parent leader with PICO and the statewide coordinator
for the California Partnership.
We celebrate the process of continuous improvement embedded into the community schools program.
Ensuring that school and district shared decision-making teams annually present their community schools
plans at the school site and district levels to remain eligible for grant funding is a
strong lever for school transformation.
In Oakland, high school teams have been required to do such presentations for the past seven
years.
Ninety-three percent of school teams reported that the process has been key to reflection,
learning, and school improvement.
Since this practice began, the graduation rate for African-American boys has increased
by 12.2 percent and the A to G completion rate has increased by 14.1.
We're excited to see an annual public presentation of a plan included in statute as a requirement
and think it should apply to districts receiving planning grants as well.
Transformation happens when students, families, community, and educators are authentic partners.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller with...
We need two minutes for...
We need two minutes for our Spanish speaker with interpretation.
Okay.
Please proceed.
Good morning.
My name is Alma Laredo, parent leader and education organizer with VHC, Padres Unidos
and Salinas, Monterey County.
We organize parents and students throughout Monterey County and also we are members of
California partnerships.
Parent and student engagement are critical and important for us and we ask for your support
ensuring that local school districts include our voices and experiences in the process.
We want that exist dialogues within the community and creativity to get data and make sure this
includes parents, youth, and students.
We don't want only surveys and information to check the box and just get the grant.
We need commitment, responsibility, and transparency, but also collaboration and the decision in
the planning process.
This will reflect equity, authenticity in the process.
The transformation happens when students, families, community, and educators are true
partners for success of future generations.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning, President Darlin-Hammond and state board members.
This is Lucero Chavez on behalf of PIKI, the Parent Institute for Quality Education.
We are a national family engagement nonprofit based in California.
We want to thank CDE and the board for your commitment to uplifting equity in the community
schools program.
The 18,000 families that we serve across California have shared with us just how much accessible,
holistic resources are needed in their communities to recover from the pandemic and to thrive
after.
I'd also like to emphasize that PIKI and other CBOs are ready to partner and share our local
and statewide expertise to develop best practices and tools to facilitate successful communities
of practice and capacity building.
Thank you, and we look forward to working together to create a community school that
reflects the needs of our families across the state.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Time starts now.
Dr. Hayen Kimner with the California Community Schools Learning Exchange.
Good morning.
We are thrilled to hear about the LEAs and the charters that have been awarded community
schools planning and implementation grants and are especially excited about the small
and rural school district that recognize that this opportunity is not just about COVID relief
or programmatic interventions, rather a successful and sustainable community strategy can
galvanize a regional partnership and systems approach that brings together the relationships
and leadership within local communities, cross-sector and departmental county resources,
and informal and formal systems of early care and education and post-secondary education.
These are the regional strengths and assets that are a valuable foundation for LEAs to
bring alignment and coherence to other major funding streams in the current budget, as
well as the anticipation of future investments, as outlined in the Governor's May Revise,
including universal pre-K, expanded learning, mental health, teacher and school residencies,
and much needed increases to school facilities funding.
Thank you so much for your time.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning, State Board of Education members.
My name is Lorraine Richards, and I am a classroom teacher representing the California Teachers
Association.
CTA would like to recommend that the next round of planning grants have a due date of
early October 2022.
This will allow for authentic engagement and shared decision-making with students, families,
educators, and communities, also allowing the creation of a steering committee.
CTA also would like to recommend that round two of implementation grants should be due
in February 2023, allowing for current planning grantees to authentically implement the structures
of shared decision-making and for the CDE to determine if the grantees are meeting their
commitments.
Lastly, CTA recommends that the superintendent's statewide advisory council be formed to play
a role in guiding the CDE through this process and help to ensure that the commitments made
by the grantees are happening.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
My name is Gustavo Lopez with the Alliance for Boys and Men of Color.
Throughout the fall, more than 600 students, families, and educators came together through
CDE-hosted forums to learn more about the community schools program.
Community members call for racially just, religious and centered schools, where power
and decision-making is shared with students, families, educators, and community, which
is the foundation of a transformational education system built by and for all of us.
Thank you for partnering and listening to the community and hosting these forums, and
thank you for centering the recommendations and visions of students, families, and educators.
Organizations from across the state came together to develop six core demands for community
schools, and now it is essential that at this point, LEAs and districts are accountable
to these commitments, especially the commitment to police-free schools that promote restorative
schools and cultures.
It is essential that we move away from criminalizations and to connections.
We're encouraged by the May revise, which prohibits funds for the community schools
program for punitive policies, and we encourage the state board to ensure LEAs and local
districts adhere to this policy.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Time starts now.
Good morning.
This is Julie Bush, superintendent of Maple School District.
I would like you to please consider rural school districts' unique realities for community
school grants.
Maple School District is a small 287-student single school district between the two farming
communities of Shafter and Wasco.
While millions of dollars were just awarded for community schools, Maple was eliminated
for the funding list.
Why?
With a 55% unduplicated pupil count, Maple does not meet the eligibility requirement,
even though it has priority as a school in a rural community and applied in a consortium
with other districts that do meet eligibility requirements.
For the last five years, Maple has been an anchor in the five-district community school
consortium, recipient of the highly competitive federal community school grant.
Together, the districts have pulled resources to address shared priorities, each district
that individually would not be able to do by themselves.
The efforts include hiring shared parent liaison community school coordinators, creating
preschool programs, establishing expanded learning programs, hiring a shared math coach,
creating a collaborative attendance campaign to target chronic absenteeism, and providing
school social workers.
Without Maple's funded participation in the consortium, the entire consortium efforts
will be impacted.
This funding criteria needs to be changed.
All students deserve the whole child approach in education.
All students deserve mental health services.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller, you're live.
You may start your comments now.
Good morning, board members.
Janice Canellan, Children's Defense Fund California.
Thank you for the new steps for community schools and collaborating around what became
community schools policy with United Ways of California in budget language last year.
Children's Defense Fund California emphasized ensuring safe school climates, eliminating
racial inequity, and improving access to trauma-responsive mental health services.
We are investing in ensuring coordination with community-based organizations and encourage
grantees to co-lead efforts with local experts, and ask for CDE and the board to emphasize
these co-led approaches and models.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Hello, this is Dr. Kendra Fair with California Community Schools Learning Exchange.
On behalf of the Learning Exchange, we celebrate the LEAs that have been awarded community
schools and implementation grants.
We urge the school board to remember for this historic investment to have lasting impact,
we must actively support community schools as part of a system change strategy.
Recipients must be supported not only in the development of powerful individual community
schools, but of community school districts, systems.
This moment rests on the expertise of decades of local implementation experience in
California, including Oakland's community school district system, the Western County
Consortium's innovative partnership across small rural LEAs, charter and alternative
schools serving students for this opportunity, and county-led work in MTSS, PBIS, inclusion,
and integrated systems of care.
Ongoing support for community school grantees must reflect the plurality of experiences
and expertise in community school implementation across the state.
Thank you so much for your time.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello, everyone.
Good morning.
My name is Lucero Soto.
I am a community organizer with Sacramento Act and a member of the California Partnership.
I am excited about this historic opportunity because this creates a space for students
and families and school communities to build together a better future.
It takes all of us to create a racially just relationship-centered community school.
I hope this brings the people closest to the pain into decision-making.
School-side and district multi-stakeholder community school teams must have decision-making
power and include directly impacted students and families that reflect the diversity of
their school community needs.
Community schools must be developed with the students and families who share power and
decision-making with educators and community-based organizations to create schools that meet
the needs of their unique community.
I am excited to continue the great work and see it blossom in our local districts.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you.
That concludes public comment for item number two.
Shift to our discussion.
I want to be sure.
Is there anybody else in the in-person queue who's added themselves to the list?
All right.
We are good to go.
So we're now open for discussion.
Nice to hear all of the enthusiasm.
Yes.
Member Patio-Branson.
I'll start us off.
I also just wanted to reflect.
I just kind of remember we had the prior innovation of allowing folks to call in for public comment
and it's just actually a lovely groundswell of bringing people in from around the state
who can't necessarily travel up to Sacramento and also just want to reflect appreciation
for all the people who joined us on the phone.
So I'll start by saying I am very excited about this motion and I think the amount of
work that has been done in such a for the time scale of a state of 40 million for all
of these gears.
I guess it's the ocean liner analogy that's probably more appropriate of turning such
a large ship to actually live into the community schools vision is incredibly exciting.
And I'm just so acutely aware that our colleagues in other states are watching what we're doing
here.
I'm also so appreciative of Steve lifting up that we are we are taking many of the best
elements in terms of sort of the four four principles framework from our national colleagues
and also uniquely lifting up what is most resonant and innovative and true to California
which is a very justice and equity based approach.
I think I every year I always sort of dwell on the state yesterday which was the anniversary
of Brown versus Board of Ed which is obviously a seminal sort of date in school histories
but it's also I think really important to think about that it was a court decision about
racial desegregation but it was also one very much about resource equity and fairness and
what attendance services and opportunities kids have based on where they come from what
their race is and what their ethnic background might be really this approach of bringing
a full whole child whole student sort of set of services and really acknowledgments of
who children are when they come into schools I think is just incredibly exciting important
and so proud of that California is leaning into this.
I have a couple of questions and so I'll maybe ask Steve to rejoin us for conversation
and having known who you were beforehand there's nothing disappointing for expectation
management.
So the first question I guess is around early childhood engagement which was raised on the
slide if you can give us a preview of next steps and what the opportunities for round
two might look like shall I do all the questions or do you want to one by one I have three
questions.
I can start with early childhood because I think it's really important for us to elevate
this and I appreciate thank you I appreciate your recognition of steering and turning the
ship and what that's taken over the past six months and as I said in my comments it really
is this team.
This line is now on hold.
I have tried for years to have that musical accompaniment to my answers.
Now I know I had to come to Sacramento to find it.
It really is a testimony to the folks who are here with me today and some of whom are
not.
But there were there were gaps and the timeline did not allow for us to engage the early ed
community the way I think we would have liked to beyond LEA affiliated early ed programs.
I would I would be less than honest if I would say that there is that there's a fully
established plan of how to do this but but certainly the intention to reach out to our
partners immediately you know upon you know us moving forward after today's vote to really
determine in the in the mixed delivery system that you and I are so familiar with how do
we how do we make sure that our our earliest learners are are going to be the beneficiaries
of this this approach certainly as they enter transitional kindergarten but no matter where
they are in that mixed delivery system and so that's a complex question but it's top
of mind and we know and I'm grateful for the partnership of first five first five
California and and a number of our other advocacy or organizations and consortiums across the
state who have said who kind of been I just want to say understanding of the timeline
that we were on but but definitely ready and anxious to engage us on how and how we do
this so what I can say is it is a priority and we are listening for the ways to to to
best to to to best engage.
One one very quick piece I just when I was looking through the documents even from our
January board item to now there were there was language that actually described early
learning as part of either supplemental learning time sort of in line with either summer
school or after school as well as whole child supports and it was previously there and it
has fallen off the page so it some one part of it I think is just also what gets named
gets remembered and addressed so as we think about round two I think making sure that the
words do sort of repair reappear on the page I think will be sort of at least a starting
point and then I'll I'll look forward to hearing more about sort of what the outreach
plan looks like.
I think the second question that is related is around data transparency and I think a
number of the folks on the call raised this up about whether any analytics would be
available in the future about both the applicant pool as well as those who were
awarded not just in terms of early ed as a one part of that but also in terms of I
think school type grade span unduplicated percentages and race and ethnicity.
I think that last one obviously just matters a ton given that we we are lifting up the
importance of the racial equity part of that and I don't know if that's forthcoming or
if that's already been collected.
I'll use the term in process.
Certainly we we are we're you know we are we're proud to be bringing a recommendation
to you today that that has prioritized our schools with 80 percent or higher unduplicated
counts of students.
We have begun to as I as I outlined in the presentation we have begun the process of
reflecting and diving deep in into the data of who applied who didn't apply who was
awarded who was not awarded beyond just the unduplicated count.
When I when I spoke of identifying community school deserts it's not just figuring out
where they are geographically it's figuring out it's it's looking at them in their
totality and understanding where the where the where those gaps are.
We've begun to see some trends but I want to be cautious on reporting on them before
we were able to look at the whole picture in terms of transparency around that.
I I think that we've we've created or or we've set some good precedent to date in terms
of our our open communication and and our transparency with the partners that we've
learned from the what you see today in this RFA process and very specifically what what
you see where you saw and continue to see in this framework was informed by the voices
that we heard.
Certainly some of us had a long time experience in some of the elements of community school
and certainly integrated service delivery but this document and the RFA approvals that
you have today go way beyond that and a lot of that is because of the open dialog and
communication that that we had both with the field and with with community and advocacy
organizations and we intend to keep that we intend to keep that moving forward.
I'll take your question a step further and say that we we also hope that data transparency
of the awardees is going to be part and parcel of of what community school transformation
means because if we are to share in truly sharing decision making we have to have equitable
access to the information and the data that guides our decisions and so so so in in short
the answer is is is we intend to have that transparency and we think that if we are to
implement in accordance with kind of the heart and soul of this movement that that's like
a threshold requirement.
And I'm I'm sure many folks will follow up to find out exactly when and that will remember
that you can lean into your mic and make sure it's on.
They're not picking you up on the line.
Sorry.
I'm just thanking Steve for for the comments and also expecting a timeline will become
more apparent and the request that you share it with us as that becomes apparent.
The last question I think and I should have prefaced this to say these are all friendly
questions.
I am totally in favor of this package and on this this issue of what does it mean to
lean into the last pillar around shared decision making shared power with community based
organizations in some ways I feel like the community schools effort leans so much into
the same lane as LCFF around being one of the largest democratic experiments really
of bringing local community voice into decision making and and also hearing from a large
number of our community partners and folks from the California Partnership in particular
asking for more clarity about what sort of assurances and structures will be built in
to ensure collaboration with the local regional the centralized TA as well as the regional
leads.
So I think that it has to be I mean let me say we're here we're here with a with a request
we're here with a recommendation that we're very we're very proud of but this is going
to be really hard work and and some of the hardest work is is around authentic shared
sharing of power and and our RFA on the lead technical assistance center leaned into the
framework in ways that I think made all applicants aware that as important as as the four pillars
that lead the national movement are as important particularly in this moment as integrated
service delivery and better service delivery better access to to services are that is not
the totality of what defines the community schools movement in California and how we
codified that in in this framework and so we absolutely need to have those accountability
mechanisms built in to every every stage of our process if you will I would be getting
ahead of the the the lead technical assistance content to to propose exactly what I believe
those should be at this moment but I believe they should be central to what we continue
to report back to this board but I think even more importantly what happens on on the ground
and in our schools and I guess I'd wrap by saying that this was the this was central
to our our our thought process our execution process and in the tool that we have available
to us so far which was which was this RFA and we what we can commit from our team is
that they will can this will continue to be central to us in every in every tool that
we have at our at our disposal so thank you for that for the question.
Got all of that okay so I just want to see is there are there any I just want to be sure
we were done with that set of questions great answers yes member Roscoe Gonzales.
Well as I expressed earlier this is a great beginning to activate engagement and to reach
students of diverse backgrounds this is a great opportunity for our state and our students
as we know transformation truly does happen when we build bridges between families students
and communities and I heard that quite a bit in our in our comments by straightening
these partnerships we truly begin to build a foundation for a community of learners and
in our diverse environment that deeply supports our students with contrasting backgrounds
I was really motivated by what some of the public hearing comments were where they express
in Spanish that they want to be socios on the vehicles which is just really authentic partnerships
within our communities and ours our schools so my question is what is the CDE's plan to
ensure that the planning grant recipients deliver on their commitments prior to applying
or receiving implementation grant funds for round two.
It's a it's a it's a great question an important question we and and let me say that I we really
we heard those comments today but also throughout this process this this desire to really be
true and authentic partners partners not just participants right and so so we are we are
in the process of developing what how we will change the second round implementation
grant RFA from from the first from the first round we expect that the commitments that
were in this planning grant RFA were not just checking the boxes.
The question was asked before the comments you know why do why how are we going to determine
why different LEAs may not have applied for for the planning grants.
We haven't heard yet that folks didn't want to make those commitments that were in that
were in the RFA but those commitments that we put in the RFA were intentional and so
as we look at the not just you know implementation grants for folks who who who had and have
been participating in existing community schools but folks who are very intentionally going
from planning grant to implementation grant that will be part of the the threshold.
I don't know yet how we will measure that that is going to be a deep engagement with
our lead technical assistance center and our our regional technical assistance centers
as we as we begin to to to develop the RFA for planning grant recipients who are then
going to move into the implementation phase but it is going to be a threshold issue to
commitments that they've made around every piece of the community school process is set
up for success in the implementation stage.
Yeah and if I could just say you know the governor's budget includes some capacity for
I think it's three additional positions and so I think you know those are all the plans that need
to be put in place that we would have some capacity to actually do the follow-through
and develop those measures and look at the analytics so I just wanted to make sure you
knew that that we are working on some capacity to be able to actually make sure that these
massive investments are are well used and that we can follow through and actually measure the
outcomes and to be able to move forward so I just wanted to make sure that that was
understood that there is some funding to build CDs capacity around community schools.
Member Glover-Woods and then member Escobedo.
Thank you and first let me say just much appreciation for just the large effort and
work that has gone into the development and the initial launch of this very important
program. I know you have worked tirelessly as has CD and SP staff and others and our
education partners to has been said a little earlier get something moving that is very very
large in a very expeditious way so thank you so much for that and as you mentioned a little
earlier there's so much more work to be done I think I will echo the course that I've heard
from my fellow board members which is implementation is key we have had a significant investment of
fiscal resources and otherwise to have a program in place to really serve our students and families
and communities that have been historically underserved and California I'm sure is under
the microscope to see what we will do with that and how it will impact students so again
implementation is key so as we move forward with our processes I don't know that I necessarily
have a question I think I have more of a comment on how essential the collaboration will be
collaboration between our lead technical assistance centers those regional tax when
they are identified as well as the county offices that are supporting the LA's and the LA's
themselves even more essential is what we heard echoed many times in the comments in the public
comments which is that authentic collaboration with parents and families and students and
communities so I look forward to ongoing updates that are brought to the board letting us know
not only the process aspects of what happens beyond the planning and the issuing of the
implementation grants but most importantly the impact it has on students both their academic
performance as well as their social emotional well-being this again is a wonderful opportunity
to really change the tide in education in California for so many of our students and
families and just looking forward to hearing more and the inclusion of early childhood and
other areas as we move forward. I actually want to emphasize what Dr. Wood said and also my
colleagues we have planning grant only thirty nine million there's two hundred and sixty million out
there so whatever we all can do to heighten the messaging on this amazing opportunity will be
welcome because definitely round two will be coming up soon and and we definitely want more
entities to be to be applying that and you know I heard implementation being critical those five
regional centers getting them online and hopefully the other three who didn't make the the main
person they would get to understand where they are in the in the process and that community getting
those five regional centers is going to be very critical for implementation purposes.
Member Olken and then maybe we can move towards a motion. Thank you. First I just want to thank
you for the presentation and also thank those who gave public comment as somebody new to the
board it's really great to hear both the professional work that's being done and the the
really good thinking across the state from those who are on the ground in our schools and working
with our schools and you know I I feel like this this movement and this investment is such an
incredible opportunity to for us to rethink what the role of school is and who the owners of
schools are and help sort of build into the fabric of public education the idea that first we center
equity and that it takes everyone in a school community to figure out how to do that well and
so the I just really appreciate the way that this is working to move that forward and my
question it's sort of along the lines of how do we move the ocean liner and and I think this
probably the answer is you'll let us know but I was looking at the timeline that was in the packet
and it's sort of year by year and but what I'm what I saw in the in the presentation was that
the between when the request went out and when awards were made was actually very fast and so
I'm sort of puzzling the urgency you know and the fact that moving something big takes time so I'm
wondering about the timeline for round two specifically time between when the announcement
is made of the potential grant and when LEAs would be responding because this is so important
those who are not in the know currently to be amongst those who participate but we miss things
I can just speak as a school later leader we miss things because we're busy and we're trying to
keep our own ships running so I'm just wondering about the timeline and how we balance urgency
and inclusivity well thank you for elevating that and that is the balance that we are that in this
next round we seek to achieve I want to be very honest and transparent urgency and the
compressed timeline were our reality for this first round and there were some deficits to that
reality we do believe that we didn't reach everyone and and we're not okay with that we
know that we know why the the urgency was there and why the timeline was compressed given the
opportunity to not work under such a compressed timeline it's our responsibility to find that
balance and to and to find the right ways to get the message to where it is not being heard or
or or received we are listening to what the best ways to do that to do that will be many of the
partners who who we heard from in public comment were in in in active engagement with as well as
partners that did not call in call in today and you're correct I don't have a full answer yet
but I also want to say that I also believe very strongly in the first part of your comments which
are you know we are really trying to change change what school means and how education is
experienced and if that is to be true no one no one in this state can can be outside of of this
process and absolutely as you've heard time and time again this is a this is an equity and justice
driven process we are absolutely intentional in the vote that we ask you to take today in
in funding literally only the schools that are 80 percent or higher unduplicated is
is not accidental it's purposeful it is designed to um to have to to alter not only the direction
of the ship but to where people look and so the first part makes the second part all the more
important and and we are we are we are listening and not what I can assure you is is that we are
not you know sitting in an office or in a in a remote setting as the case may be just kind of
figuring this out and saying well this will be best for the field we are listening actively
to determine what that balance should be thank you for the question okay
I'd like to make a motion member Escobeda I would like to motion on the three recommendations for
approval the first one is to recommend that we approve the round one planning grant award
this the second is to confirm the round one implemented implementation grant award and third
to pass the CDE's lead technical assistance center contract award I can did right any further
discussion all right all in favor say aye and raise your hands
I just want to be sure we're
definitely certain and then are there any nays any abstentions nice to see you back
Rana and we hope your international baccalaureate test went well
well the motion passes and you have earned a break so we'll see you in about 11 minutes
it's 11 24 we'll see you at 11 35 where's my gavel
this is the most fun
good part of you back in place don't get to do that on the zoom okay I'm not I'm not seeing it yet
now that I've got your attention we're waiting for the countdown
and I'll just uh all right
okay all right welcome back our next item is the what we call the mega assessment item
we call it that for a reason because it usually has multiple parts so we may after the presentation
depending on how we're doing time wise at that point we may break for lunch in mid item and then
return and I will keep you posted it's likely that we would in that case have the public comment
after lunch but we'll sort of see where we are time wise I don't want any
decisions made when the board members are hangry so
we will monitor this carefully and so we're about to look at item three which involves
the california assessment of student performance and progress system and english language
proficiency assessments for california the CDE is recommending that we approve the per
pupil apportionment rates for the 2021-22 school year for the casp tests as provided in table one
of attachment two and the per pupil apportionment rates for the 2021-22 school year for the LPAC
tests as well in addition the state superintendent of public instruction proposed initial and
summative alternate LPAC threshold scores are proposed and for approval to be effective
beginning in the 2021-22 administration and this item will be presented by Tracy Albee and Julie
Williams of the CDE with an introduction by our assessment director Mao Vang Mao nice to see you
please begin thank you thank you board president darlin ham and our esteemed board members
and as well as our chief deputy superintendent mary nicely thank you as mentioned i'm mal vang
director of the assessment development and administration division of the california
department of education the item before you today is both an action and an information item
lady later in my presentation i will be joined by multiple staff however initially we will have
tracy albee our administrator join us and then julie williams will join she's a consultant
going over our national and international assessments also to present also present
excuse me and to assist with questions today we have maryann arcella she's the executive director
for ets our assessment contractor here we also have tony alper executive director of the smarter
balance consortium and linda hooper the associate director for assessment development administration
division to help us with any potential questions and then i'm gonna go ahead and proceed as
um mentioned our presentation today will cover an overview of the california department of
educations or cde's recommendations as for approval of the portion and rates and the
alternate english language proficiency assessments for california or lpac threshold scores
then we will go over some california assessment of student performance or progress
and progress or casp and lpac updates during this update we will be joined by sheryl cotton
our deputy superintendent of the instruction measurement and administration division
as well as our chief deputy superintendent mary nicely will join us to give a status of the test
administration currently as well as the calpats upgrades and impact to statewide testing so we
get a few of us joining on this mega item and then furthermore we will cover the national
international assessments update for you and then circle back finally to our cde's recommendations
for your approval and action okay with that um
again as stated the recommendations here the cde or the california department of education recommends
that the state board of education approve the 2021-22 per pupil apportionment rates for the casp
tests as administered as part of the casp system as provided in the table one of attachment two
of the item and then the 2021-22 per pupil apportionment rates for the lpac tests that
are administered as provided in table two of attachment two of the item and then the proposed
state superintendent public instruction or sspi's initial and summative alternate lpac threshold
scores beginning with the 2021-22 administration as shown in attachment four of this item
and then now let's move to our first recommendation will be which will be presented
by tracy albee and she is the administrator of our english language proficiency and spanish
assessments office within our assessment development and administration division
here you go tracy thank you dr bang
thank you president darling hammon and board members again i'm tracy albee and in this section
i will go over the 2021-22 proposed apportionment rates for the casp and the lpac
so the cde recommends that the state board approve the following proposed per pupil rates
for the tests administered as part of the casp system during the 2021-22 school year
we start off with our smaller balance summative assessments for english language arts or literacy
and our mathematics at a per pupil rate of four dollars california science test
two dollars california spanish assessment five dollars california alternate assessments or caa's
for ela and our math five dollars and the caa for science five dollars and grade two diagnostic
assessments for ela or mathematics which are optional at two dollars and 52 cents and finally
students that have not been tested due to medical emergency and parent and guardian exemptions
these are the same rates that were approved by the state board of education
in may of 2021 for the previous administration year
next the cde recommends that the state board of education approve the following rates for tests
administered as part of the lpac during the 2021-22 school year starting with the initial lpac
kindergarten through grade two five dollars and 50 cents initial lpac grades three through 12
grades three through 12 five dollars initial lpac rotating score validation process identified
students in kindergarten through grade 12 an additional 50 cents per student the summative
lpac kindergarten through grade two five dollars and 50 cents and the summative lpac grades three
through 12 five dollars this year recommended apportionment rates for the lpac are the same
as the previous year with one exception the new assessment the alternate lpac operational field
test has been added to the apportionment rates and is seen in that final row with the addition
of the alternate lpac operational field test which is a one-on-one administration the cde
recommends an apportionment rate of five dollars and 50 cents per pupil for kindergarten through
grade 12 this is similar to the initial and summative k2 lpac administrations which are also
one-on-one i will circle back to the cde's recommendations toward the end of the presentation
but i am happy to answer any questions clarifying questions you may have now
okay
i will move on now let's move on to the next recommendation for the alternate lpac proposed
threshold scores
also present to assist me with questions are the following colleagues from educational testing
services or ets kelly bolton who is the interim director for assessment development
and patty barron strategic advisor for standard setting so the background for the alternate lpac
the test was developed to comply with the following requirements it is administered pursuant to the
california education code sections 313 and 60810 it is aligned to the 2012 california
english language development or eld standards via the eld connectors which are reduced in depth
breadth and complexity for this specific population in 2019 the state board of education approved the
alternate lpac general performance level descriptors or plds and the score reporting structure
it is important to note that the work accomplished during the alternate lpac standard setting process
was guided by these board approved plds and will be provided to the u.s department of education
as part of the federal peer review of this new assessment
the alternate lpac measures the english language proficiency of students with the most
significant cognitive disabilities as determined by their individualized education team
and whose primary language is a language other than english it is administered to students in
kindergarten through grade 12 either upon first enrolling in a california public school
or annually for those students identified as english learners each spring it is set
sorry it assesses the receptive listening and reading domains and the expressive speaking
and writing domains through items that are given to or that using a student's preferred
communication mode for example a student may point to gesture or use an augmentative and
alternative communication device or ac device to respond to the items
this slide outlines the work leading up to this request for approval of the alternate lpac proposed
threshold scores the development of the alternate lpac began with the state board approval of the
high level test design performance level descriptors and the reporting structure in 2019
the state board of education then approved the alternate lpac test blueprints in 2019
test blueprints in may 2020 which were the same for both the initial and the summative alternate
lpac in 2021 a field test began in november and will come to the close at the end of this month
during the field test window the standard setting workshop was conducted at the end of february
beginning of march of this year all that work brings us to today's request for approval
of the alternate lpac threshold scores once approval is received the initial alternate
lpac will be administered for the first time beginning this july and the summative alternate
lpac will be administered starting on february 1st 2023
a detailed standard setting plan was approved by the cde and submitted to the state board of education
as an informational memorandum last month the standard setting approach utilized a modified
and extended angoff methods the modified angoff method is used for one point responses
and the extended angoff method is used for two point responses with both methods panelists had
to consider the knowledge and skills that the threshold student has and the knowledge and
skills needed to earn one point and two points both of these methods are widely accepted and
adhere to the guidelines and best practices recommended in the standard setting literature
later this fall a standard setting technical report will be posted which describes this
process in detail the next loose sorry the next few slides provide an overview
of the standard setting process that was used
as described in attachment six of this item the panelists were comprised of 44
diverse california educators who represented the three main regions of california central
northern and southern they had varied ethnicities and included perspectives of classroom teachers
and local educational agency or lea or county employees they had experience in teaching
students learning the skills assessed with the alternate lpac lastly nine of the 44 educators
participated on more than one panel as this standard setting workshop occurred over two weeks
the first step in the standard setting process was to review the alternate lpac items
the panelists then reviewed the performance level descriptors to define the knowledge and skills of
each threshold student using these definitions the panelists made two rounds of judgments on
the likelihood that students at the threshold would answer each item correctly with discussions
between each round here is a little graphic we love to share so the alternate lpac there are
three performance levels level one is novice english learner level two is intermediate
english learner and level three is fluent english proficient therefore two threshold
scores are needed for each grade level or grade span the panelists were tasked with
reviewing the performance level descriptors or plds and defined the knowledge and skills of that
threshold student for levels two and levels three in other words what does performance look like
for that student who is just into level two and just into level three that is the solid pink
character for level two and the solid blue character for level three that are indicated
on this slide these threshold student definitions are also referred to as the threshold plds
these descriptions are an important tool that the educator panelists used to make their recommended
threshold score judgments okay so the modified and extended angoff methods were implemented
for one point and two point items the panelists made judgments on the likelihood that each of
the two threshold students level two and level three would answer each one point item correctly
and what score this threshold student would achieve on the two point items
panelists made two rounds of judgments with discussion between round one and round two
at the end of round two each select panelists from all six grade level groups also participated in a
vertical articulation meeting which allowed the panelists across the grade levels and grade spans
grade spans to confirm the alignment of these threshold definitions
that was a simplified overview of the approach and does not fully convey the depth
of the content and conversations that occurred at that meeting
the panel judgments are presented in tables one and two of attachment five of this item
after the cd's review of the panelists judgments the cde consulted with members of our lpac technical
advisory group our assessment interest holder group and the state and federal program director
these reviews resulted in minor adjustments to the panel's judgments and yielded the proposed
state superintendent of public instructions recommendations provided in attachment for
table one and table two
the data for this slide is the data for the two point and two point items
the data for this slide and the next includes all students who were administered the alternate lpac
operational field test the slide includes the proposed threshold scores and impact data
for the initial alternate lpac during the process of establishing threshold scores
we use a temporary standard setting scale shown here in the far two right hand columns
for following the state board of education approval these thresholds will be applied
to the reporting scales which are the values that will be presented on our student score reports
the threshold scores were applied to all items in the field test item pool for both the initial
alternate lpac and the summative alternate lpac test forms to maintain the fidelity of the with
the work of the standard setting panel the state superintendent of public instructions recommended
recommended thresholds are within two conditional standard errors of measurement of the panel's
recommendations that is all adjustments are within the natural area variance around the panel's
recommended thresholds and therefore reflect only slight modifications to of their judgments
the initial alternate lpac will be administered to eligible students for the first time beginning
july of 2022 as a reminder this is a snapshot using student performance on this year's operational
field test the student performance when the initial alternate lpac is administered may differ from
these percentages on the slide and may change over time given that the eligible initial students
are a much smaller subset of the group that was administered the operational field test
next are the state superintendent of public instructions recommended thresholds for the
summative alternate lpac which are the same as those for the initial
except that the grade 9 through 12 threshold for the initial alternate lpac were split into two
grade spans 9 and 10 and 11 and 12 the thresholds were then applied to the students within those
grades who took the alternate lpac field test and resulted in the values in the last two rows
of this table on the slide
okay upon the state board of education's approval of the alternate lpac threshold scores the cde
will notify the superintendents and charter school administrators of the approved thresholds
and student score reports the cde will then conduct a quality control process to evaluate
the data and ensure that the information on the summative alternate lpac student score reports
or ssrs is being reported accurately if all goes well the ssrs will be delivered to lea's to share
with parents and guardians at the end of july this year lastly as was done for the general lpac
two separate threshold validation studies will be conducted in the 2020-22-23 academic year
for the initial and summative alternate lpac more information on these studies will be provided
to the state board of education when they become available
and i am happy to answer any clarifying questions you may now have
okay are there any clarifying questions yes member oaken um just these may be questions
that you don't know the answer to but thank you for this by the way this is
amazing work that's being done um i'm curious once this is implemented do we have a sense of
how many students will be participating do we know that and then my second question is
what were those students doing before um first of all um how many students do we have currently
we have um that are taking the actual operational field test we have um just over 20 000 students
that were registered to take and then for those that since we did not have an alternate english
language proficiency assessment in place they would take a locally determined alternate assessment
and they would use that information to determine services
okay excellent i will turn it over to miss
thank you tracy well we as i i mentioned earlier we will be in this section we will cover the
casp and alpaca updates and i have sheryl here our chief deputy superintendent
good afternoon everyone it's 1202 uh again my name is sheryl cotton i am deputy superintendent
of the instruction measurement and administration branch for cde
and i will begin with casp and alpaca updates cas consists of smarter balance for english
language arts and math mathematics tests the california science test or cast the california
alternate assessment or caa for ela math and science and the california spanish assessment
the alpaca consists of the initial alpaca summative alpaca and alternate alpaca operational
field tests we just talked about next slide thank you we'd like to update you on the current status
of testing administration and upcoming plans for state assessments the state assessment testing
window runs from mid-january through mid-july lea select their testing window within the state
window for their lea and their schools the selected testing window must end at the lea's
last instructional day or by july 15 whichever comes first
the every student succeeds act or essa requires all states to test at least 95 percent of all
students and student groups in english language arts and literacy or ela in math and science
it also requires states to factor the participation rate into their accountability systems which for
california is the academic indicator as of monday may 16th the estimated statewide percentage of
students who have completed cas testing are as follows smarter balanced ela 81 percent and math
77 percent and 66 percent for cast are our california science assessment for the california
alternate assessment i'm sorry for ela 61 percent for math 58 percent and for science 47 percent
and for csa which is an optional test it's at 61 percent of those registered over 50,800 students
are registered to take that test we're really excited about these numbers this shows a positive
trend toward reaching the federal requirement of at least 95 percent of students tested across the
of students tested across the state so it's looking really good next slide please
the lpac summative testing window ends on may 31st and as a reminder the initial lpac remains
open until june 30th 2022 100 percent of all eligible english learners must be administered
either the summative lpac or the alternate lpac operational field test as of monday may 16th
the estimated statewide percentage of students who have completed lpac testing are as follows
initial lpac 98 percent summative lpac 75 percent and alternate lpac operational field test 77
percent again more good news now i'll hand it over to chief deputy mary nicely to provide an update
on calpads upgrades and statewide testing and highlight key issues and some of our solutions
thank you
oops which one am i talking into this one
good afternoon right now i don't speak to you as chief deputy mary nicely i speak to you as the
branch deputy of the information technology branch so if you and so you may be wondering why am i
doing this um because i have responsibility for all of our our technical services division
our calpads division under edmd and our accountability and measurement branch
which are all responsible along with mal in ensuring that we have accurate data reporting
on our dashboards and can report back to you are the assessments and and keep the lights on
and so some of you may have heard about a an upgrade to the calpads system which is
over a decade old and had been managing literally hundreds of millions of records
our lea's have been clamoring for an upgrade for many many years because some of these updates
could take more than 48 hours we are really proud to be able to say that we have sped that up to a
by 20 times and so we are able to process instead of in 48 hours 14 minutes the types of records and
we have gone over a million records a day being processed now so we're really excited to be able
to do that of course there's always hiccups as a programmer myself there's always hiccups when
you're rolling out a new system and some of those hiccups unfortunately took place during testing
but we're really glad to be working very closely with ets our contractor to ensure that those
problems are met we have put together a cross-departmental team that is working
endlessly overnight to ensure that we are addressing all of the technical issues
and bug fixes which could have taken up to three weeks previously and we are knocking out about 38
issues on a bi-weekly basis to get those things out and we're working really closely with our
education partners with access SSC sba and our small school districts association so that they
can see the progress that we're making and whether they want them or not they're getting our bug fix
lists every night so that they can address the needs and the questions that the superintendents
are facing so some of the things that we continue to have taking place manually is the processing
manually of the ets data twice a week into the system and we've had some issues over a couple
of days which i think are being remedied now with just a capacity issue prior to covid schools would
have to schedule in a lab to have kids come in and take a test now the silver lining of covid was
one-to-one computing devices the downside of that is that now everyone can flip open their
their laptop and their chromebook and start taking a test which i think hit some capacity
issues with our test our contractor they have reached i think at the maximum was
about close to 500 million or 500 000 on may 3rd and so they've been doing some
load balancing capacity for that and can now take up to 2 million users concurrently so we continue
to work with ets and communicate regularly with test coordinators and it departments to let them
know where we are we've got alerts going out we've they've got web pages that are up with statuses
so i just wanted to let you know at this point we're working this is a top priority of the
department to ensure the smooth running of testing and as cheryl said we're excited to see that our
numbers are actually higher than pre-covid for some of our testing and assessments at this point
and we're keeping a close eye on any of those lea's that are having any kind of difficulty
getting in and being able to reach those 95 thresholds right now we are looking at
last week we already had our first wildfire in orange county so we're looking at that we are
dealing with some issues with some cyber security on some of our other lea's and so we're working
very closely to to manage those and keep an eye on those situations with our data so that is an
update and if you want we'll put you on that mailing list so you can get those technical updates
from us as well so thank you
thank you mary thank you cheryl for providing that update that's very helpful i know that we're in
the thick of testing and it's always good to know that we're all coordinating and making sure that
the local educational agency staff have what they need to continue with testing
so we're going to provide another update with you in another little area
in continuing with the updates we have an update on the smarter balanced
demonstration of concept study so during the last two board meetings or so our division has
been providing an overview and an update on the demonstration of concept study
and it is being conducted by smarter balance the assessment consortium in partnership with the
teacher the new teacher center ntc and this is the first year that we're doing this one it's
an initial look at how performance tasks can be effectively incorporated into classroom
instruction and it begins to build a knowledge base about the possible use of embedded performance
tasks as part of a large-scale assessment a summative assessment so specifically this
study aims to answer basic questions like can the p performance task pt stands for performance task
be administered flexibly during the school year aligned with the local contacts and can
a support activity better prepare students for the cognitive demands of the performance task
and what support and development do teachers need to gather and analyze critical information
to inform improve and accelerate student learning so these are the basis for this study and these
are some of the questions we're trying to ask and find out so um well we the performance task
use for this year's study came from our english language arts and mathematics smarter balance
interim assessments and we do have two i mentioned before the but i will say them again because they
are wonderful local educational agencies that is participating and that is upper lake unified
and valverde unified so you know on behalf if they're listening or watching on behalf of the
cde we really like to extend our gratitude to these two local educational agencies for their
participation and commitment to this study because they will help us learn and a total there was a
total of 63 teachers from these two local educational agencies that participated
they represented grades four five six and high school and since march teachers have
attended the professional sessions learning sessions that were brought to them and then
they also implemented a performance task support activity and they also administered and scored
interim assessment performance tasks and planned instruction based on data that they gather from
the student performance and during the professional learning sessions the participants did share
information including their students responses from the classroom activities and feedback from
teachers were also about regarding student progress as a part of the analysis for the study
so the administrators from each of the local educational agencies also participated in these
professional learning sessions so it wasn't just teachers there was support from the top as well
and a preliminary report including the benefits and challenges of the embed of embedding performance
tasks into classroom instruction will be available in june 2022 so next month in a few weeks the
preliminary report will reflect initial findings and recommendations for future research into
implementing a through-year approach and then a final report which will include the additional
analyses is expected in late summer so continuing on the preliminary evaluation of feedback and work
from the participating teachers suggests that in part the support activity that preceded the
performance task did help teachers find strategies that they can use to support their students
toward greater success on performance on the performance task however more guidance
for teachers is needed on how to support students as they transition from the collaborative nature
or structure of support of the support activity to the independent work of the actual performance
task so the integration of the formative assessment process was seen throughout this study
and used by teachers and they indicated that was useful to inform instruction so again
further details about the findings and recommendations from the preliminary report
will be presented we believe we could bring this to the state board at its july meeting to give you
further update and more detail
right so we're flying i know i'm right between lunch so i'm gonna zip through some of this
okay so another little update for you because we do many exciting things in assessment it's not
just it's not just testing we provide just an update about the 2022-23 california educator
reporting system trainings so we have this california educator reporting system and we're
going to provide these trainings throughout the year they're really two to three hours trainings
because soon we're going to roll out the scores of all the students testing this spring into this
educator reporting system so they'll be able to have it readily available to them so these
separate sessions are designed for two audiences we'll have one for our assessment coordinators
and administrators and then one for teachers and others who have similar staff roles so that they
could best utilize the system and then we will record them we will make them available for
them to go back and and utilize or view them and then registration is open now just a little
plug in there the interim assessment formative assessment trainings the series is also happening
these are really three hour online assessment training sessions for teachers and this summer
we're inviting local educational agency staff to come to this
and I'm sorry it's also in the fall as well and there's three modules module one module two module
three module one engages or uses the formative assessment process and the tools for teachers
website to support or boost instruction and then model module two gauges student progress with the
smarter balance interim assessments and all the other various online systems that support
the interim assessments then in module three uses hand scoring to analyze written responses
using expect understanding expectations and determining instructional next steps
for that module and then again they're going to be recorded and made available and we have that
registration open as well our science instructional resources so with the tools
for teachers we're able to build as we've shared with you in our updates build additional science
instructional resources for the for teachers and embed it into that same system tools for teachers
so we've completed four workshops and 59 science instructional resources are available
just want to let you know that this july we will conduct another in-person workshop in sacramento
and we're going to plan on developing 15 additional resources so let me see and of course
one of the highlights is that these there are
our five experienced resource developers who are science leads and then you know the other
15 educators will also will act as the developers of the resources so they're really built by
california educators for california educators and of course our cde staff will also work as
trainers and assist and coach the educators in their development process and they will receive
that same peer review process that was used in the previous workshop so that the resources
are vetted very well and they'll be available this fall that is gold
again we continue to work with the smarter balance assessment consortium because we are part of the
consortium and this summer there are two workshops held in july for members of our state network of
educators what they call our snes or sneeze to develop over 150 ele okay that was mathematics
instructional resources for the tools for teachers oh you you guys needed a little pick me up anyway
so one exciting thing i want to share with you is that smarter balance is expanding development
into including english language arts resources for kindergarten through grade two so that's a
new thing we're doing and there are about 80 educators from about 23 23 of them are from
california they're going to help with this development and then of course our staff will
also be on the leadership team to help with the development as well and and that is exciting i
think we're going to oregon for that so all right so i'm gonna stop talking because i think i always
say too much um and i'm gonna hand it over to my very capable julie williams she is our consultant
and single-handedly really um coordinate all of the national and international assessments for
california would you like me to
greetings president darling ham and esteemed board members and chief deputy nicely it is an
honor to present this update to you today i'll try to keep it very brief uh seeing as the time
uh yes thank you so um the national and international assessments in which california
schools participate include the following the national assessment of educational progress or
nape also known as the nation's report card the international computer and information
literacy study which some call icils i just call it icils because that's easy okay the progress
in international reading literacy study or pearls the program for international student assessment
or pisa my favorite and the trends in international mathematics and science study or tims so
i'm going to refer to them by their acronyms from here moving forward these assessments are all
coordinated through the u.s department of education's national center for education
statistics or the nces and the cd's assessment development and administration division
or me and um they are all administered by field staff that contract with the ncs schools do not
have to administrate these tests themselves at present okay this slide shows a brief overview
of all these assessments that were conducted in 2021-22 in california schools so nape is the
largest nationally representative and continuing assessment of what u.s students know and can do
in various subjects it was mandated by congress in 1969 for 2022 approximately 430 california
schools out of 10 000 participated in nape representing the diversity of california and
the nation about 50 students per school were randomly selected to take the nape in a single
subject and over 20 000 california students took nape this year nape takes students about two hours
to complete and all of these assessments as well as subject matter content a student is offered
a short survey of their educational experiences and this provides rich contextual data
that we can correlate with student scores so between january and march of this year
nape conducted the following grade four and eight math and reading to be reported at the national
state and large district level there are 30 large districts that participate in california
it has slimmed down to just two districts los angeles and san diego unified fresno unified
dropped out of that district level program this year these results allow us to compare
achievement trends over time and between jurisdictions participation is required for
schools in districts that accept title one funds grade eight civics and u.s history to be reported
at the national level only and age nine long-term trend math and reading assessments to be reported
at the national level only so nape 22 results will be released as the nation's report card
by early 2023 i'm hearing late october 22 perhaps that will be determined by the national assessment
governing board next we have the field test for isles so isles is an international assessment of
grade eight computer and information literacy administered every five years since 2013
isles 2023 will draw students from over 30 countries and results from this and all the
other international assessments are used by researchers and policymakers to inform discussions
of international competitiveness isles takes students about three and a half hours to complete
in april last month isles conducted a field test to inform the development of the assessment
and fewer than 10 california schools participated in this isles field test approximately 30 will be
selected for isles 2023 pearls is an international assessment of grade four reading literacy that's
administered every five years since 2001 the fall 2021 pearls administration drew students from over
50 countries pearls take students about three hours to complete and the number of california
schools participating in pearls 2021 was 14 results for that will be out probably early 2023
a field test for pisa so pisa is an international assessment of 15 year olds
that measures how well they apply their knowledge and skills in reading mathematics science and
financial literacy it's administered every three years since 2000 with over 80 countries
participating this assessment takes students about four hours including breaks to complete
in late september 2021 pisa conducted a field test to inform the development of the assessment
and fewer than 10 schools participated in that field test will have about 30
for pisa 2022 coming up this fall a field test for tims tims an international math and science
assessment administered in grades four and eight administered every four years since 1995 with over
65 countries participating this assessment takes students about three hours including breaks to
complete in spring 2022 tims conducted a field test to determine whether questions are biased
because of national social or cultural differences and to confirm that field operations work as
intended fewer than 10 california schools participated in the field test for tims
next slide please follow us on twitter everybody okay and uh next slide please
i am happy to answer any clarifying questions you may have now
i think the giggling means we have a lot of low blood sugar up here
um are there any are we at the end of the item yeah okay so we could take clarifying questions
we are going to take public comment after lunch and so i will you know allow any clarifying
questions and of course i'll ask member arosco-conzales who is a liaison to the
assessment group if she has any comments at this time
um okay i'll turn it back to dr vane to present the cd recommendation for approval yes why don't
we get those we're not going to vote yet we're going to discuss when we come back from lunch
but we can have them as a reminder right here okay yes so circling back our recommendation
for approval today are um again the cde or california department of education recommends
that the california state board of education approve the following the 2021-22 school year
per pupil apportionment rates for the california assessment of student performance and progress
or casp tests administer as part of the casp system as provided in table one of attachment two
of the item and the the 2021-22 school year per pupil apportionment rates for the english
language proficiency assessments for california or alpac tests administered as provided in table
two of attachment two of the item the proposed state superintendent of public instructions
initial and summative alternate alpac threshold scores beginning with the 2021-22 administration
as shown in attachment four of this item
okay so um thank you very much let's put up the um slide for a public comment call and we're going
to invite people to call in for about 30 minutes from now we're going to get lunch in the meantime
it is 12 31 we'll be back down here by about 101 give or take a minute and at the moment i think
we have no in-person public comment if there is any online public comment or telephone public
comment please call us at one o'clock all right there we go
all right we are reassembled welcome back and we're going to now resume on public comment on
the assessment mega item do we have any in-person public comment
we do not so for those who are calling in if there are any call the conference number that
is on the slide and use the participant access code and i want to ask if there's any public
comment on on the phone we do not have any public comment all right well moving right along we want
to we're now we're now open for board discussion and mao is here for all of all of our questions
and the recommendations
this was easier than i thought it might be we could have maybe finished before lunch but
here we are we've got any other uh discussion i do have one just kind of
point of clarification it was interesting to hear that smarter balance is looking at the k2 space
and i just want to be mindful of the fact that we are now with tk revising the preschool learning
foundations and developing a seamless strategy up through grade three so we would definitely
want to start to think about how those things are are coming together
yes were you raising your hand i was not but you were okay
i i really need i really need the zoom thing back
member arusco gonzalez you have a question you guys are getting silly
we're giddy because we had sugar now so we had the sugar yeah um i just want my comments just
the smarter balance plans to host the 80 educators as a resource authors for workshops i personally
was trained in 2013 from smarter balance and some of those resources that i use now
are quite rigorous and a great opportunity i looked through your tools for teachers and saw
a few exemplary performance tests that i thought were great for tool for teachers to to engage
students into meaningful activities in their classroom and i think it's a great start so
my comment is just a positive one that i think they're in the right direction when it comes
to performance tasks and opportunities for teachers to get training and what i really
appreciate is that we go into the direction of teacher-led workshops where teachers then
go back to their school sites or their districts and then share some of this knowledge so thank you
for that is there if there's no is there any other discussion or questions if there is oh
okay member rodriguez um i just have a comment about the the tasks and the process with the
teachers and i i really appreciate that i appreciate um especially i think the mind
shift that needs to happen from teaching to the test to teaching how to think and how to process
information which is you know a shift that is so necessary in our educational system these days
so thank you for that all right we will hear more i think in potentially in july about the
proof of concept also that's going on with the performance tests in the classroom so
we'll look forward to that and if there's no other discussion i'd love to see if there's a motion
to adopt the recommendations i motion that we adopt thank you very much is there a second
okay very good all in favor please say aye
aye any opposed nay any abstentions all right motion passes thank you very much
mao and tracy and julie and sheryl and mary
and we're going to move right ahead to the waiver consent calendar
so we'll want the public comments slide up for the waivers and first we'll take up the
waiver consent items w1 through w10 we'll now open the public phone line for public
comment on the waivers please display we've got the slide the members of the public wishing to
provide comment on this item may do so by calling the telephone number and using the access code
provided on the slide that is shown now we will take in-person public comment first so we ask
members of the public who wish to provide comments to be ready to line up when your
names are announced by sb staff if there are any such people and so are there any speakers signed
up for public comment on this item somebody's going to look
we're waiting okay there's no in-person public comment are there any callers dialed in for
public comment there are no callers in the queue as well all right um so then we will
ask for a motion our waivers w1 through 10 do have a motion
thank you is there a second thank you very much all of those in favor raise your hand
any any opposed any abstentions motion passes thank you very much item four is the consideration
of a request for determination of funding with reasonable wait did i that's it yeah
the determination of funding with reasonable basis mitigating circumstances as required for
non-classroom-based charter schools and cde recommends that the state board deny
sierra foothill charters mitigating circumstances request and approve the determination of funding
request at 70 funding for two years as provided in attachment one the item will be presented by
stephanie farland and mccain ahuey of the cde please begin good afternoon president darling
hammon vice president glover woods and members of the state board executive director alan
we're happy to be in person today today we are
going to talk a little bit about determination of funding funding requests for non-classroom-based
schools and we have some new members so we're going to go over a little background and context
for these items so prior to jumping into the details of the of this item some background on
the statute surrounding determination of funding requests so pursuant to education code 4761 2.5
d1 a charter school that has an approved charter may receive funding for its non-classroom-based
instruction only if a determination for funding is made by the california state board of education
a determination of funding is required in order for charter schools to receive funding for their
non-classroom-based average daily ada average daily attendance if their classroom-based ada
falls below or is anticipated to fall below 80 percent of its total ada so this is not something
that all charter schools have to do it's just those charter schools whose non-classroom-based
ada fall below the 80 threshold which we're going to describe in just a few minutes
just to give some context uh for the new board members and for the board members who have been
here for a while and don't add it up in their own minds over what's happened over the last five years
the cde notes that from january 2017 to march 2022 the state board has heard 540
determination of funding requests of those 540 funding determination requests 81
40 funding determination requests 81 have included the consideration of mitigating
circumstances which is the type of funding requests we're hearing today a funding request
with mitigating circumstances and so for some context the board has approved 97 percent of
funding determinations at the 100 level so really close to 100 this board has been
has approved funding determination request at 100 97 percent of those that are mitigating
circumstance funding requests have also been approved by the board so and and also just to
add some context the state board has also denied a school's mitigating circumstances request
based on its high reserves before so this is not an unusual or unique circumstance that we're
bringing forth today so the process
for the funding review and recommendation process so pursuant to california code of
regulations title five section one one nine six three point four the cde reviews the determination
of funding requests and develops a recommendation on the request and if necessary we will ask for
additional information which you will hear in this presentation we did so in this case
the cde presents its recommendation to the advisory commission on charter schools
the accs considers the information presented it makes its own recommendation to the state
board of ed both the cde and accs's recommendations are presented to the sbe and you will hear both
today so as we move to describing the criteria and all of the details for the funding
determination i'm going to pass it over to mckenna huey who oversees the funding
determination request in the charter schools division
good afternoon um my name is mckenna huey as stephanie farland just stated
um so going into the criteria for determination of funding education code section four seven six
three four point two a one specifies that the state board shall adopt regulations setting forth
criteria for the determination of funding for non-costing based instruction and at a minimum
the regulation shall specify that the non-costing based instruction is conducted for the instructional
benefit of pupils and is substantially dedicated to that function in determining the amount of
funding to be allocated to a charter school the state board shall consider the amount of the
charter school's total budget that was expended on certificated employee salaries and benefits
on school sites the teacher to people ratio in the school and any other factors that it deems
appropriate
pursuant to education code section four seven six three four point two a four for the 2003 2004
fiscal year and each fiscal year thereafter the amount of funding determined by the state board
shall be not more than 70 percent of the unadjusted amount to which a charter school
would otherwise be entitled unless the state board determines that a greater or lesser amount
is appropriate based on the criteria specified on the previous slide
so california code of regulations title five section one one nine six three point four a
provides a criteria that shall guide the process of reviewing and developing a
recommendation on determination of funding requests pursuant to this section a charter
school requesting a determination of funding may qualify for either 185 70 or zero percent
the following table outlines the criteria for the different levels of funding and to qualify
for a proposed recommendation of 100 funding a non-classroom based charter school must meet
the following criteria they must spend at least 40 percent of the school's public revenues on
salaries and benefits for their certificated employees spend at least 80 percent of all
revenues on instruction related services and maintain a people to teacher ratio of 25 to one
california code of regulations title five section one one nine six three point four e permits the
finding of a reasonable basis or mitigating circumstance by which to make a recommendation
other than one that results from the specified expenditure criteria on the previous slide
so specifically other information provided by the charter school on the funding determination form
such as the charter school's contracts governing board members and reserves or documented data
regarding individual circumstances of the charter school such as one-time expenses may be considered
so this item oh sorry this item consists of a request for determination of funding with
reasonable basis mitigating circumstances from sierra foothill charter which is a classroom
based charter school now typically funding determination requests are not submitted by
classroom based charter schools as their classroom based ada remains well above the 80 percent of
their total ada however the cde does recommend that classroom based charter schools submit a
funding determination request if they are near the 80 percent threshold or if they anticipate
that their classroom based ada will fall below the 80 percent threshold to prevent interruptions to
the school's funding should the school's classroom based ada decreased unexpectedly
our funding determination has no positive or negative impact to a classroom based charter
school's funding if it remains above the 80 percent classroom based ada threshold the purpose of the
funding determination is really to just allow the charter school that has less than 80 percent
classroom based ada to receive funding for its non-classroom based ada
so a little bit of background as previously stated education code 47612.5 does state that a
charter school that offers non-classroom based instruction may receive funding for that instruction
only if it has an approved funding determination from the state board however senate bill 820
section 75 modified this process for fiscal year 21-22 and exempted and exempted schools with the
funding determination that expires on june 30th 2022 from the requirement to obtain an approved
funding determination rather these existing charter schools automatically receive their current
level of funding for two years upon their submission of a complete and timely funding
determination request their funding determination requests do not require approval by the state
board so this school that we're hearing today cr foothill charter does not have an active funding
determination that expires on june 30th 2022 and is thus required to obtain an approved funding
determination from the state board which is why we are presenting this item today
so pursuant to a california code of regulations title 51963.4 a charter school requesting a
determination of funding may qualify for either 70 85 or 80 percent of the funding
may qualify for either 70 85 100 or 0 percent funding and again the criteria is outlined here
on this table sierra foothill charter does not meet the expenditure requirements for a recommendation
of 100 funding for its non-classroom based instruction per regulations the school
qualifies for a 70 determination of funding as it reported spending 37.2 percent on
certificated salaries and benefits and 74.9 percent on instruction and related services
so because it did not meet the expenditure requirements sierra foothill charter did
submit mitigating circumstances for consideration the school cited its receipt of approximately
135 000 in s or three funding as a reason it did not meet the criteria for full funding
without this one-time revenue the school would have met the requirements for 100 funding
the cde does acknowledge that the s or funding that sierra foothill charter received was one time
in nature and was a unique or exceptional expense and does constitute a mitigating circumstance
however the cd notes that the school reported a total reserve of approximately 940 000 which
makes up over 61 percent of the school's total expenditures additionally the cd notes that the
school reported an average daily attendance of 122.26 for fiscal year 2021-22 pursuant to
california quota regulations reserves in excess of greater of 50 000 or five percent of total
expenditures may be allowed for economic uncertainties or long-term expenditures such as capital projects
if the excess reserves are satisfactorily explained when asked by the cde
sierra foothill charter did not state any specific plans or their high reserves
so sierra foothill charter failed to meet the regulatory expenditure requirements for a
recommendation of 100 funding pursuant to regulations the school qualifies for 70
funding for its non-cost and based instruction without the consideration of mitigating
circumstances when considering requests for mitigating circumstances the cde takes into
consideration not just the mitigating circumstances request but other information provided by the
school on its funding determination form as well as information provided by the school and its
follow-up communications with the cd pursuant to regulations which does state that the cd may ask
a charter school to provide additional information in order to make possible a
more detailed review or to develop a reasonable basis for a recommendation pursuant to regulations
the cd considers other information provided by the charter school including its reserves
when a school fails to meet the expenditure requirements for the recommendation for full
funding unlike previously heard schools with large reserves sierra foothill charter did not
articulate plans that would require additional funding above its existing robust reserve
since this is since this request was presented to the accs at its april 12th meeting
the cde has received no other communication from the school regarding its plan for its reserves
as such the cd has determined that the information submitted by sierra foothill charter
does not support its claim for mitigating circumstances while the school did obtain
one-time revenue that impacted its expenditure percentages the school had a sizable reserve at
its disposal that could have been sent spent on certificated salaries and benefits and
instruction related services the cd does have concerns that sierra foothill charter spending
patterns do not demonstrate that they are spending at adequate levels for the students that they serve
i'm going to go ahead and turn it back to stephanie farland for our recommendation
so as we stated earlier it is recommended that charter schools classroom-based charter schools
who have who have a feeling a fear a projection that they might fall below that 80% threshold to
submit a funding determination request sometimes we don't have to use them at all and in this case
it's very likely that they won't have to use this one based on numbers that come in on their p2
based on numbers that come in on their p2 so
so moving forward i just wanted to reiterate that that they don't always use them the
classroom-based charter schools we do it just in case so we don't want their funding to be
interrupted or impacted negatively in any way but there's a very good there's a very good
chance that this school will not even have to use this funding determination request
um we are recommending the department is recommending today that the sbe deny
sierra foothill charter is mitigating circumstances requests and approve their
determination of funding at 70 for two years we do know that the school may submit a reconsideration
request to seek a higher level of funding during the effective period of its funding determination
pursuant to regulations so at any point in the next two years if indeed they do need to use it
and they manage to meet the 80 threshold they certainly can come back for
a reconsideration and we do have schools that do that here to the sb
as stated earlier it did go to the advisory commission on charter schools
at its april 12 2022 meeting the accs did not agree with the cv's recommendation instead moved
to recommend that the sb approve sierra foothill charters mitigating circumstance request
and approve their determination of funding request at 100 for two years that motion
passed by a vote of six to one and that is our presentation so thank you thank you thank you
so much stephanie and mckenna right now we're going to open the public uh the phone line for
public comment and members of the public wishing to provide comment on this item may do so by
calling the telephone number and using the access code provided on the slide that is shown now
we will take in-person public comment on this item first so we ask members of the public who
wish to provide comments to be ready to line up when your names are announced by sb staff
uh while we're waiting um we will ask for uh some initial comments from member oaken
on this item and i will make some comments as well before we go to public comment
really i'm first okay um well um first of all thank you for your report and for the um
for the explanation of sort of over the course of time what these determinations look like
and um it's super helpful to get the history in the background um this was my first um advisory
commission on charter schools meeting and so um it's really still trying to understand the players
and um the rules and regulations um but i really appreciate the
ongoing attempt to help me understand how this works um and um you know my understanding is
it in in the time since this was first brought for a funding determination we haven't received
any more information from the school is that is that correct that is that is correct and so um
i'm gonna stop there for now um yeah i just um
you know i i appreciate that in this time budgets are um complicated we don't always
know how much funding we're going to receive when we have to pass our budgets um and that
our first important rule is to try and get as much money as possible towards our students um and so i
appreciate the continued efforts to understand what the mitigating circumstances and where how
that money is going to be spent on kids in program um because at the at the heart of it that's what
that's what we need to be doing so thank you
and i'll just add my uh comments i also attended the accs meeting with member oaken
and uh we'll say there was a robust conversation um as it relates to this particular item uh and
again to underscore for my fellow board members that the funding determination request was made
and cd did reach out for additional information as it relates to the reserves at that time and
had not received information but i'm quite encouraged uh stephanie as you mentioned in
your closing comment that they may not need the funding determination um at all but it's good to
know that and i appreciate again the historical background that you provided on actions the
board has taken in relation to these type of items uh so again a good conversation the
information as of right now had not been received from the school for cde to
make any further determinations if you will as it relates to their request
um my question is since you met on april 12th um and the accs did not accept the cds
recommendation my question is does the advisory commission um usually disregard the cds
recommendation um i don't know if they disregarded it they just didn't agree
but no i would say more often than not they they are in alignment but they certainly have their
own opinions and and they come from various backgrounds and so um yeah they do not always
agree with cd's recommendation okay just want to make sure i'm not familiar so thank you yeah
any other uh it i'm sorry this is a procedural question is this i i got a little flummoxed
because i wasn't sure if we were doing um public comment or clarifying questions
well you do clarifying questions then we do public comment okay so i do have a clarifying question
um which is um about um what um what you mentioned about not needing a potentially not
needing a mitigating or a funding determination um can you explain that that's new information
um i will try um yes i'm not in the funding division but um the way i understand it is that
when they look at their p2 turn in their p2 numbers it could have changed um in terms of
the funding the the ada could be back up above 80 percent so usually when these classroom-based
schools uh submit a funding determination they're usually right on the fence
um of thinking either we're going to dip below 80 or above or you know dip below 80 it's usually
not by huge margins um and so by the time when they submit their funding determination to the
time where they um submit their p2 uh ada figures it could change and so in this case um i don't
have i don't i mean i can't confirm it but based on what i'm hearing is that they may not need to
use it after all um because they're not no longer below the 80 threshold so they'll have to confirm
that when in our sfsd division will confirm that when when um they release the the data that comes
in for the p2s but it's um it's it's that that's why because it can change the ada changes from
the time they submit their funding determination to the time that they confirm their p2 ada
can i just ask a further question and um so um so the just to make sure i understand
for a school that has both classroom-based and non-classroom-based um for a charter school that
has both classroom-based and non-classroom-based instruction if the classroom-based instruction
is more than 80 percent of their ada then they do not need a funding determination
right 80 percent or more yes okay so and so this is i hope this is helpful for anyone else because
it's making sense to me now and so um and so what may have changed is the ratio of their
classroom-based program to their non-classroom-based program and then this funding determination would
be moot because they would go with classroom-based apportionment yes funding got it okay thank you
just add one other clarification we will nonetheless be voting on the original
recommendation in case it is necessary and if there are no other clarifying questions
we will go to public comment we have one in-person public comment i believe
and then we'll go to on the phone public comment
i think i got this microphone figured out i'm a pro now you could hire me before it good
afternoon everybody i'm still michael juba representing the california teachers association
cta would like to express our support for the cde's recommendation to deny
sierra foothill charters mitigating circumstances request and approve the determination of funding
requests at 70 percent funding for the next two years the cde as you heard clearly outlines in
the item the rationale for this recommendation and they communicated with the charter to receive
additional information as stated in the item there were many non-classroom-based charters that apply
for funding determinations with large financial reserves and based on cde's due diligence in this
matter it is clear that there is no basis to approve the mitigating circumstances and it is
unclear why the commissioners of the accs would recommend overturning the cde's well
reasoned recommendation so cta would recommend that the spe adopt the cde's recommendation on
this item thank you we do we have one caller in the queue i will open the phone line now
please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now you have one minute
hello it's eric premack with the charter schools development center
i'm not here to represent the school in question we actually don't know them very well and i'm very
concerned that they may not understand the gravity of this because they're really a
classroom-based school i'm here though because we're very concerned that cuts of this huge
magnitude would send a signal to many other charter schools that they need to essentially
dump a ton of money out of their budget and now in june 30 and that's a concern that i think the
accs very much shared and very important to understand the gravity of the signaling that
your votes on these items take and so for that reason we fully support the accs's recommendation
notwithstanding our respect for the work that cde has done here thank you very much
thank you okay that concludes public comment for item number four
we'll turn to board discussion is there discussion of the item now
yes thank you president darling hammon uh just wanted to uh bring forward a point i believe that
was said during the presentation but to underscore for our our board members that
in moving forward if the school does need to avail themselves of the funding determination
and if the board were to approve or move to approve the cde recommendation the school does
have the opportunity to come back and request the full funding 100 of the funding determination
within that two-year period so just wanted to clarify that as we make a decision and
however the board chooses to vote that the school does have the opportunity to come back if needed
um is there other discussion yes member patio branson um just it's so striking that um the
school did not reply to cde's uh opportunity to describe um other uses of the reserves and i think
puts it in a pretty unique place um from the the types of determinations we've had to um
make decisions on before um the only thing that i would just flag is um i just wonder if there's a
way to um address the signaling issue um obviously that's not a board decision that's a communication
issue um but that was raised by the call-in um person uh but otherwise i i think it's one of those
but otherwise i i think it's one of those lack of of uh substantiation or response even i think
just speaks volumes unfortunately and um that that sort of i think makes it pretty clear yeah
and and they they didn't and and you know we we certainly we certainly don't um advocate getting
rid of reserves for charter schools we know how important reserves are for charter schools um
and i i take a little issue with the callers identifying it as dumping money out um you know
that money is allocated to schools to use for students and teaching and learning so we would
never advocate any charter school to dump money just to be able to get to 100 it certainly wasn't
the case here we've had charters come up on these case on mitigating circumstance items before with
large reserves and they had uses for those reserves that we took into consideration and approved
them for 100 so it isn't a signal to the field that you can't have large reserves um it's a
signal to the field that you should use lcff right the charter school non-classroom they should be
using it appropriately um and if they find themselves in this circumstances mitigating
circumstances we just need to have really just a reasonable reason as to why they have such high
reserves um so yeah i i certainly wouldn't want that uh signal to go out to the field that the
department or or the board doesn't believe in a strong reserve for for charter schools um and in
this case uh you know we we didn't get and they didn't call in either so um i don't know if that
just points to the fact that they think they'll probably not need it um but but yes there has
there has been a lack of communication uh member escobedo and then member olken well i'd like to
add that you know these funds obviously are needed to be used for student learning teaching and when
i look at their own l cap and this is benchmarked from spring of 2021 43 percent of students aren't
meeting standards 37 not meeting ela standards yet there's funds there to help students with
tutoring to help students to perhaps some other modes of of of enhancing their learning or helping
teachers enhance their practice as well i think the message is you know you have the resources
use them for the purpose they're given to you and there is a need at that school
thank you member olken
this this was a a good learning experience for me in terms of um
thinking about the way um funding really gets at our mission i guess you know it's they're so in
so um deeply connected um and i would be remiss if i didn't say you know this is a time as a
as a charter leader and i actually think for all public school leaders this has been a time where
finances have been very unsure and we see districts across the state really struggling
financially we see the instability that happens for teachers when that happens and the pink slips
i mean it's a time i mean i'm really excited about the the budget news for next year because
maybe we're turning a corner on it but i i think it is it's not surprising to me that schools would
be trying to maintain some level of stability in these unstable times um that said i started by
saying i think you know our budget is our is our mission statement or it's at least reflection of
it and it it could be for um for seara foothill but because they haven't given us information
about why they're um why they spent their money the way they did and we just are left guessing
it it gives me pause and it was that information that i would need in order to um you know not
in order to question the really great work of um the department of education um and we just
didn't receive it and so i can't read tea leaves you know so anyway thank you any other discussion
of the item all right uh do i have a motion i'll move the cds recommendation to deny seara foothill's
charter application for mitigating circumstances do i second thank you uh any further discussion
all in favor say aye aye any opposed nay any abstentions all right motion passes thank you
um i think we're going to move right ahead to um move into our regular consent calendar which
includes items five through eleven uh we will now open the phone line for the queue for public
comment on consent items five through eleven members of the public wishing to provide comment
on this item may do so by calling the telephone number and using the access code provided on the
slide that is shown now while we're waiting for people to call in we'll take any in-person public
comment in the boardroom is there any in-person public comment
there there is not and we'll give it a little bit of wait time because sometimes there's a lag
for folks who are trying to call in so give it a few minutes a few seconds and by the way i was
asked to remind you when you're speaking to lean into the mic because the live feed has had some
trouble picking some of us up i just reminded myself so i'm now reminding you
is there any uh telephone uh comment and we do not have any callers in the queue
all right uh so do i have a motion
thank you member lewis a second okay thank you uh and uh all in favor say aye
aye any opposed any abstentions all right uh we the motion carries and we're going to move
right on to reopen item number one which is to take action on the preliminary report of the
actions from the draft march 2022 meeting minutes and to have members report on their liaison
assignments um while we're waiting for any members of the public to call in we will have
that back up again uh i do do i have a motion from a board member to approve the march 2022
state board of education draft preliminary report of action meeting minutes so moved
second i see member patio bronson is trying to be right on i think we have a little race going on
mostly trying to remember to lean into i need buzzers or something right so
um all right uh so we have the uh motion we have the second are there any public comments
before we vote uh no there are no public comments is there any further discussion
seeing none uh all of those in favor say aye all right any opposed any abstentions
we have an abstention sharon was not here yep that's great so now we're going to do our liaison
reports uh and i want you to report out on your uh liaison activities that are not related to
items on the may agenda so i'm going to uh call on our board members in alphabetical order based
on their last name uh and i'm going to start with rana and ron i i understand you have some news
about where you've decided to go on to college in uh in next year and i will let you give your
own news although i'm bursting to tell it well thank you president darling hammond um yeah i
decided to um commit to stanford so i'm really excited thank you um it's great to see everyone
here in person finally um i really apologize for arriving late today i had my final ib test this
morning um of course it was tons of fun as you all may guess um but i'm really happy to be here now
um first of all i want to recognize teachers appreciation week which happened earlier this
month um teachers are truly the foundation of our education system and i am so incredibly grateful
for all of the teachers i've had not just this year but but throughout my educational career
um they've always supported me they've always made sure that i understand even the difficult topics
math um and and they even take time out of their days and that they're not even being paid and they
you know support students and so um you know i just want to thank all of the teachers across our great
state um for all that you guys do um continuing with the theme of shout outs i want to shout out
niomi porter um who was recently appointed by governor newsome to be next year's student
board member on this board uh she's an incredible student and a passionate change maker and so
i'm really excited to start prepping her for the role over the summer um and then recently i was
able to participate alongside students from across the state um in a webinar with the department
of public health about the impact of coven 19 on schools and just thinking about ways that we can
move forward um and there was a really great diversity of perspectives there which i really
appreciated um and i felt like i could personally learn a lot from the just the various perspectives
that i was able to hear in that webinar um so students emphasize the importance of expanding
after-school access to tutoring to remedy the learning loss that happened last year
the importance of listening to student perspectives when trying to make decisions
about moving forward and students students also said that they felt like it would be beneficial
to make sure that students continually understand the status of coven 19 because while there are
some districts where all of the students pretty much are still wearing their masks and they're
still being very safe there are also districts on the other hand which are kind of moving on
and almost seems like they forget that cove it still exists and so i think it's just important
to make sure that everyone stays informed and is aware um and then looking forward i'm excited to
be speaking at a webinar this friday hosted by senator padilla where we'll be discussing the
impact of covid on mental health which i'm sure you all know is is very broad and and there's
definitely a lot to talk about there so i'm looking forward to that um and that concludes my board
report thank you so much and congratulations we'll see you on campus member escapado
yes wested
uh
a great meeting with wested and we'd like to invite my colleagues on i believe is june 9th
they're they're having a um they're hosting a presentation by by heather mcgee who authored
the some of us what racism costs everyone and how we can prosper together and it's
actually very timing and she is an economist and she looks at racism through the eyes of
the economic conditions in our in our state and how those lack of opportunities not only
has affected the quality of life for people of color but mainstream america as well
and the degradation of our society can all be connected to the lack of economic opportunities
so i'll send you all you know that length it's only an hour um should be quite a unique
perspective and on how to look at racism from a different lens also wested is looking at um
the evolution of formative assessments and how um they can they're looking at um establishing
a new way uh to inform teachers throughout the year and um working with states like new york
and incorporating a different type of assessment and information system so more on that a little
bit later thank you i had an opportunity to attend the april convening of the instruction
quality commission it was the first time that that particular group of commissioners has been
able to meet in person and uh was quite a jovial mood in the space i will definitely say that
for the commissioner some who've only seen themselves through the screen to get together
similar to us today at that particular meeting uh there were a couple of topics that were
discussed that i'll highlight very briefly for all of you one was that they received an update
on the comprehensive uh literacy state literacy plan and so information was provided on just kind
of an overview of the work that had been done to date but also there was a sharing of the online
literacy resource repository that is under development and will be accessible to educators
another really exciting uh update if you will that took place at the iqc meeting was in regards to
upcoming model curriculums and there are four very important areas that will begin to start the
process of developing and they are native american studies vietnamese american refugee experience
cambodian genocide among history and cultural studies so we will definitely keep you posted
county offices and those who will be working together to help develop those model curriculums
as well as others have been identified and will start to convene and again i will continue to
keep the board updated and the last uh portion that they talked about was another update if you
will on the california digital learning integration and standards guidance we were able to hear
the resources that are available online as well as videos and things of that sort to help support
educators in that digital learning space which we know is very important for some of our students
as well and president darling ham and that concludes my report thank you
member louis
okay uh thank you the um committee that i sat in on was the waiver committee and it was a very uh
enlightening meeting and i really learned uh from that meeting we actually went through the waivers
and then i was given information regarding the articles that give us waiver authority and also
the policies regarding some of the the waivers that were on our agenda so one meeting very
informative i like the process of going through and discussing each of the waivers and and finding
the merit as to whether they stay on consent or should be brought to the open group so i really
appreciated the deep discussion and explanation behind those and look forward to working with
that committee as well i believe my other one is the iqc but i missed the meeting
you have more to say next time cover woods did an outstanding job even though i wasn't there
i know it was right on point right on point all right wonderful uh member mccullin
all right so nice to meet all of you in person after two years of zooming together so
it's great to see you um not a whole lot to report from my position uh we're looking forward to the
next uh joint pathways career technical education committee coming up i believe i think on june 10th
that hasn't been confirmed yet we've been trying to find a date that works
member glover woods what you said is very true that there's a lot of buzz around california around
the model curriculum especially american indian model curriculum there's a lot of tribes who are
buzzing about that wanting to give input and very excited about that so looking forward to it that's
it thank you all right thank you uh member olken thank you uh i just want to echo also it's so great
to be here in person with you all um i i'm gonna have to stop saying i'm new soon because we're all
new together today um my i am the i'm serving as a liaison to both the advisory commission on charter
um my i am the i'm serving as a liaison to both the advisory commission on charter schools and
the advisory commission on special education um in terms of the advisory commission on charter schools
we already covered the main topic of that meeting today um and unfortunately i was not able to attend
the meeting i don't think i had been actually assigned yet to the meeting on um the the
advisory commission for special special education but i received the the materials um and they're
really amazing um there was a one set of materials on and a report on the impact of universal um
pre-k on special education and um what that might mean for being able to identify and support
students at a younger age and then there was another set of materials on the importance of
social emotional learning and support um so things that um are topics i think near and dear
to all of us here thank you that concludes my report great um member roscoe gonzalez
i know you mentioned that um mine was part of the mega item as a liaison assignment but i just want
to have a comment about that about how important is the work that they're doing on demonstrating
the proof of concept for the performance tasks um some of the things that we're doing in our
district that is similar to what smart balance is doing is preparing those cfas which are pretty
much a performance test and we've seen that by the collection of data that students are learning
more deeply and being more engaged in their own learning by doing several tasks versus one you
know common response um test or so i think that's really important work and i think some of the
stuff that um i thought was really great was the science instructional resources for tools for
teachers um the resources that are being provided for teachers to to look at and to curate for their
own classrooms um is a great database and a great start for the students in california so i'm excited
to see the work and the proof of concept in the fall in the fall or late summer correct okay so
that's what i have to report thank you
and uh member patiya branson
hi um and i'm i'm not on my phone except for my notes
so i had my first meeting um which was super exciting to um actually talk with the california
state summer school for the arts um and um it's been a really um exciting sort of moment of change
for them i think um so they went virtual um as so many um organizations did uh during the pandemic
and they are back in action for this summer they'll be having about 500 students from across the state
who will be joining them in a host of artistic uh pursuits um they also have been doing some
really interesting work to lean into their mission of serving uh the the full diversity
of california kids um and so they have uh changed some of their um rubric um in terms of looking at
admissions um to encourage um both via recruitment as well as looking at the application process
to encourage more first generation college going students and also to do greater outreach at title
and schools um and what's exciting is in the a fairly short amount of time they have been able
to actually see real results um and a greater geographic distribution a greater distribution
of different uh fields of art and also socioeconomic and racial diversity um so it's i think a lovely
success story and just want to lift up the leadership of matthew gallagher who's the
sort of new uh ish ed there who has been leading a lot of really great work um i'll also
flag that um i had the opportunity to meet the secretary of education cardona down in
southern california as he was doing a tour uh and meeting with school board members and he was both
fantastic representing our president's education agenda and certainly lifted up i think three key
themes um that will sound very familiar given today's discussion uh one around the need for
mental health which i think is absolutely a core part of the community schools offering and also
i'm excited to know that rana will be representing california alongside senator pedia to raise up
that issue um also the necessity of tutoring after school and summer programs to help with
learning loss and learning acceleration and then lastly the need to address the teacher shortage
and teacher retention efforts and what what was i think really heartening is those are all big
challenges that california shares with a lot of other states and that california is already
leaning quite heavily into all three of those areas in a way that i think speaks well of our
leadership and how we are um addressing each of those um the last thing i'll just say um is
this is actually more referencing last year's budget but sort of seeing the fun
effects when i think state and local work together so in last year's budget uh the governor proposed
in the legislature came together on child savings accounts which begin children and families on a
journey of thinking about college savings and training for post college which is where we want
we do our jobs right in k-12 then they go on to the next system and and do incredibly well and if
they have a nest egg of savings there's great studies around the importance of how that shapes
their notion of what they can do next there's also now a local effort there has been for many years
in san francisco to have a similar child savings account um lusd just debuted um it's as well so
that uh all first graders across the district will have additional contributions for child
savings accounts and there's there's a healthy buzz a couple amongst a couple of other school
districts so sometimes innovation starts at local and sort of floats up to state and sometimes it
starts at state and floats in circles around the state um and that concludes my my report
awesome thank you member rodriguez thank you president darling hammond um and fellow members
in public so um i have some very good news about national board uh the national board incentive
the professional teaching standards certificate incentive program year one numbers 1,818 teachers
in high priority schools pursued national board certification this year compared to 341 teachers
from high priority schools in 2021 so those were big numbers yes 1,955 national board certified
teachers in high priority schools will receive the first five thousand dollar installment
of the uh twenty five thousand dollar incentive reward and cd has done a phenomenal job with
outreach partnering with professional networks and labor groups and administering the program
to get these great results and i encourage any teacher in the classroom to
pursue national board certification there's there's something very powerful about having
a common language to reflect on one's teaching and to improve our practice to better serve our
students um going on with the teacher shortage so i was invited to be on a pep committee and at
first i thought i'd be chairing but it it stands for public education positions and yeah but i was
still chairing um and it's actually through nasb the uh national association of school boards of
education and so this particular committee um basically you know the work is presented to
the the assembly and it's it'll be like what the resources of the staff and the organization will
focus on uh for the coming year and so um i'm on the teacher shortage teacher preparation workforce
team and we've been and and i think the reason why i ended up on that team is i was
i kept citing uh lpi teacher shortage articles that i'd read and then all of a sudden
i became i became the person and so uh anyway we're working very hard to present something in
october and uh enthusiastic that you know we'll have yet another uh partner agency working working
on this crisis and making sure that we're recruiting teachers and i'd also like to
encourage career changers i'm a career changer i didn't go straight from college into teaching
and i think that it's uh i know it's the best decision i ever made so um lastly ctc is looking
for um school employees and we mentioned today that it's a school employee week for the teacher
credentialing program that was started about four years ago and it's very successful
and it's people that work within the school who can apply to become teachers and they're
supported throughout the process so it's very powerful if you know somebody who you know works
in the front office who's always like oh i want to go back to school and i want to be a teacher
and they already have relationships with the students so this is a wonderful program
they will be accepting applications until june 10th and lastly educator preparation student liaison
for the ctc is also uh an open spot and they are looking for applicants if you know anybody
who is in a teacher preparation program um they would they're the voice right you know the liaison
that represents um that particular student population and the application is due before
june 30th president that concludes my report oh wonderful well i'm going to offer just a couple
of um examples of things that are of the ways california is being talked about in the policy
arena sometimes i'm doing the talking sometimes other people are but but things that made me
very proud to think about and i think they will make you proud too i was in a meeting of the
collaborating states initiative of the castle organization the collaborative for academic social
emotional learning and um california was identified as a state that has really taken a holistic
approach to social emotional learning restorative practices so i was asked to sort of just help
people understand the pieces of it and it was a really interesting reflection because
starting some years ago when i first came to california in fact there was a zero tolerance
law that required student exclusion from school for a set of offenses that you know you sort of
had to suspend or expel for and that was changed you know that law was ultimately eliminated then
there was legislation to eliminate willful defiance as a reason for suspension suspension
was put into the accountability system for the federal accountability elements along with school
climate part of our eight state priorities money was put into professional development
for social emotional learning restorative practices the ctc enacted standards for both
administrators and teachers requiring that social emotional learning and supports and
restorative practices be part of what people learn to do the state undertook a multi-tiered
system of support initiative and over with all of those things going on which is much more
comprehensive than states usually approach these things as we've had a huge decline in suspension
a corresponding increase in graduation rates and a big big improvement in school safety so it was
just really nice to be able to think about the fact that over this last decade or so we've really
tackled some of these you know concerns from multiple angles and then i'll just also let you
know that we recently got word brooks knows this that california has been selected for the frank
newman award that the education commission of the states gives out for state innovation
and the comment about that was that no other state is really doing such large structural long-term
reform as as california so leaving us on a high note like we began with you know may being the
time for recognizing accomplishments i think the hard work that everyone in this body and our
companion bodies in government is doing is is moving us forward so that's a good way to go into
the summer right and so with that we're going to take up our last agenda item which is general
public comment public comment is invited on any matter not included on the printed agenda
members of the public wishing to provide comment on this item may do so by calling the number shown
on the public comment slide and i guess we'll give it a moment and see if there's anyone waiting to
provide public comment is there anybody in person waiting to do so i don't see anybody in the audience
yes but just checking
and is there anyone who's called in to provide public comment
there there is one caller in the queue there is no caller in the queue
there's one there's one there's one okay go ahead please uh please offer your public comment
please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one moment
one minute your time starts now
thank you my name is beth kelly no affiliation i'm just a parent i just wanted to make a comment
about the california math framework the draft one that's available and i'm really disappointed
in it i think that it it kind of dumbs down math education and and unfortunately isn't based in
best practices around math you know as a as a middle class person i can bypass the system by
you know getting supplemental math outside of school but we really shouldn't have to do that
no kid should have to do that and at a minimum i really urge you to make the framework more user
friendly so that teachers can actually utilize what it is right now it's like over a thousand
pages and and it's not useful and and also at a bare minimum it's important to get rid of
the there are various misstatements about the research that is cited
and i just at least i want something to be passed that has integrity thank you very much for your
time
yeah hi um my name is joseph sky campbell and i am a candidate for the state superintendent of
public instruction i also work in monastery education i publish books about monastery
education i worked with a lot of great educators i can tell there's a lot of great educators
listening to me right now i want to just express my appreciation for the board especially for
for the president dr darlin hammon you guys do a lot to support the kids of california
it's a joy to see the meeting so you guys having a good time laughing i'm glad you're there in
person um i do i want to express a little concern about some of the school closures
scheduled um in oakland and i i didn't come on to make a fuss i'm going to follow up hopefully
with the president dr hamlin um darlin hammon but uh if not hopefully someone from the state
board i got a couple questions and i know there's a little controversy concerning that um
but yeah just thank you guys so much for doing everything you do for the thank you call your time
is up thank you that concludes public comment for item number 12 right and as we started the
meeting with we know we're going to have a deep dive into the math framework at some point so
we'll have many opportunities to take account of all the many comments and with that i hereby
adjourn our may 2022 state board of education meeting at 2 20 p.m thank you and i look forward
to seeing you in july